johnny depp has won
this is big news and it's a lot of
celebrity gossip that i haven't really
followed all that much but there is some
big cultural political uh victories here
there are some
this is a huge blow to the believe all
woman me too stuff amber heard wrote
this op-ed that was basically defaming
johnny depp without actually naming him
because it was part of the whole
narrative about how you know women are
abused and they have to keep it secret
turns out well you know she's got to pay
damages to johnny depp now he did lose
some of the
of the case but for the most part major
victory for johnny depp and a major blow
to believe all women and the corporate
press because i believe it was the
washington post who just uncritically
ran this story like yeah sure you can
say whatever you want
and my question is why isn't johnny depp
suing the washington post so i don't
know maybe i mean everyone can't sue
them
uh what do you mean the washington post
is that a dare no
yeah sure maybe they can so we'll talk
about all that we also have man today is
kind of crazy we have this uh the
democrat who's running against rand paul
made what may be one of the most insane
political ads i've ever seen it's him
with a noose around his neck and he's
holding on to it talking about how you
know it was terri like it was a tool
that terrorizes people and i'm just like
yo if you think this is like the woke
stuff was crazy 10 years ago just wait
until these woke millennials
are running the show completely as
opposed to just
suggesting or demanding of these things
imagine when they're actually at the
helm i think he won the jesse small ed
vote man oh for sure for sure and then
we have
this one's going to be tough because
youtube's going to get real mad about
this one
hunter biden okay apparently texted his
father a link to adult content but it's
hold on call the best case scenario
that's the best case scenario yeah
yikes so
the daily mail says but wait
they shared phone numbers oh so maybe he
was just sending it to himself and then
i'm like yo that means it could be joe
sending it to his son
there's a whole bunch of new information
coming out from this laptop the creepy
things that hunter biden does but i got
to be honest you know if hunter bond
wants to do weirdo stuff that that's
fine he can do his thing and i don't i
don't think it's anybody's business but
when you've when you learn that through
these links that were being sent they
shared phone numbers it raises questions
about whether or not joe was actually
doing business pretending to be hunter
that's the real story so we're going to
talk about all of that plus we got some
joe rogan stuff in the news we've got
some other cultural stuff in the news
woke movies failing joining us to talk
about all of this is joe bob yo what up
uh my name is joe bob i feel like i
should first and foremost explain that
ridiculous name
uh one grandpa was joe the other one was
bob my parents couldn't decide who to
name me after and so they compromised
and yellowed uh
a hillbilly alabama backwoods name on a
brown guy so there's that um when when
uh lydia was like we have joe bob on i'm
thinking like some guy in overalls like
a straw head i definitely cool i
definitely have more teeth of any job
you've ever had here if you've had any
other jobs bring you in for diversity
training like i want everyone to picture
someone named joe bob now open your eyes
[Laughter]
so what do you do uh i uh i've been in
politics for a while uh i somehow
convinced the good folks at daily caller
to allow me to host the daily caller
live show each and every morning on all
the daily college platforms uh and i say
somehow convinced because i'm holy and
entirely unqualified to do that sort of
thing i mostly make jokes about the news
try and reach an audience that's kind of
like not so into the weeds
maybe we can talk about why a little bit
later but yeah that's kind of my my
thing i also do some stuff with turning
point usa i'm a contributor over there
and cool have been uh this is all very
new to me so i'm pretty good we also we
also have brett dasavic joining us host
of pop culture crisis because i gotta be
honest i don't know a whole lot about
the johnny depp stuff and we needed
somebody who could tell us more about it
i think there's cultural and political
ramifications here but brett's joining
us speaking of wholly unqualified and
talking about stuff to people who might
not know uh the stuff you're talking
about that's kind of what we do over
there is you kind of uh link in stuff
that's uh socio-political into cultural
commentary talk about it in the context
of movies and we kind of do that and i i
totally identify with the feeling
unqualified while speaking to people on
the show so that that's perfect you read
more about it than i did of course shim
sham shim sham over here on shim cast
irl i'm seamus coughlin uh i make
cartoons on a youtube channel called
freedom tunes we uploaded a pretty funny
cartoon about the canadian gun band
yesterday i think you guys will enjoy we
are uploading a cartoon tomorrow i think
you'll also enjoy and guess what we
launched our website freedomtunes.com
you go over there become a member for
five bucks a month you'll get four extra
cartoons per month that'll be exclusive
only you folks will get to see them and
we've got a bunch of videos up there now
waiting for you at least five cartoons
and a bunch of behind the scenes stuff
and if you are a member of our freedom
tunes make sure you just demand more
fouchy more fouchy yeah we can do look i
mean you become a member you leave a
comment if you want more tim is fauci
we'll get more tim spouchy in there oh
she's gone man and you will come back
you will or will not love them forever i
will love them forever
[Laughter]
it is um i want what is best for them
speaking of holy unqualified
wow dudes everyone here is like i
shouldn't yeah
ian crossland in the house everybody
let's get to it because i've never known
any two people to share a phone number
before so yeah
that's really interesting
you missed a point too it also could
have been joe sending it to joe that's
right is that what you were going to say
yeah something like that joe's like this
evening i really like this link man
make sure i don't forget about it oh my
god that actually feels more plausible
giving it i don't know dude my honest
opinion is i think joe biden abused his
son
i would i'm not sure but we'll get into
i'm not kidding yeah for sure no i don't
think so not at all yeah even just
abandonment
i don't want to bury the lead so i'll
just say
we know he sniffs kids
look how screwed up hunter biden is yep
the drug abuse i think that dude's got
long-term trauma from something happened
in his life and now they're texting each
other porn yo i think that dude but
we'll get into that stuff anyway yeah
i'm also here i am qualified to push
buttons and nothing else i'm glad to be
here even though the top content of this
is kind of gross i'm looking forward to
hearing what brett has to say it's gonna
be good before we get started head over
to timcast.com and become a member in
order to get access to exclusive
members-only segments from the show
we're gonna have a show up for you at 11
p.m tonight monday through thursday is
when we put these episodes up but you'll
also be supporting our journalists we'll
hire a couple more you'll be supporting
our infrastructure we are working
diligently behind the scenes to build
a culture and infrastructure around
opposing censorship so we're hopefully
gonna have some updates on that in the
future but uh you know that we um
switched over to rumble's cloud
infrastructure we are not done we are
still building stuff and as soon as
we're ready we're gonna make some big
announcements and keep making big
splashes in that area don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show right now take
that youtube url post it on every social
media platform if you do want to help
out that grassroots marketing is the
most powerful way you can support us
let's jump into this first story from
timcast.com
jury finds amber heard defamed johnny
depp in trial verdict heard order to pay
15 million dollars in damages but i
don't think that's where it ends
there's there's some there's some caps
and there's uh i think johnny johnny
does oh some to uh amber so let's read
the seven-person jury reached the
decision around 3 20 p.m on june 1st
after deliberating for a cumulative 12
hours over three days
heard had been has been ordered to pay
15 million dollars in damages however 5
million of the of that amount applies to
punitive damages with which the state
caps at 350 000
in herds counter suit that was found
guilty of one of three counts of
defamation depp was not present in the
courtroom at the time the verdict was
read although he did teleconference in
from the united kingdom
depp filed the defamation suit against
herd for 50 million dollars after
alleging the op-ed she authored for the
washington post damaged his reputation
his legal teams at the actress presented
herself as a public figure representing
domestic abuse which had financial
consequences for her ex-husband even
though it never specifically included
his name and he's won
in a huge blow
for the metoo movement with all of these
just you know believe all women
narratives just no matter what well now
we know that amber heard wasn't being
honest and also the corporate press the
washington post that uncritically
ran this story which is what they often
do and then they what they want to hide
behind oh but it was someone else's
opinion well here we are i don't know if
i missed anything in that story brett
there's more details you want to you
think we should mention uh the most
important one that i think a lot of
people leave out is that she didn't
write that's right
she uh it was drafted by an aclu lawyer
[Music]
if i can remember
and that was basically done uh to
coincide around the time of her uh
leaving uh johnny depp and uh we talked
about it today there's a lot of like
really um weasley language in that op-ed
like i was surprised how short it is
like i hadn't read it in a long time i i
skimmed it when it first came out right
and when we went back through it the
other day i mean it's only about a
paragraph it's a couple paragraphs long
and most of the stuff about johnny depp
could be inferred in like that first
paragraph and the rest of it is just
very very um generalized language so
that's why i was surprised that he
actually did end up winning so this
sounds like
a hoax
uh the i think it was you didn't write
it uh she did not write it she it was
drafted basically by somebody as an aclu
lawyer because she was a spokesperson
for the aclu on domestic violence wow um
and that's a problem because it was done
at the time of his uh of them getting
separated divorced this is this is more
than just me too and corporate press
this is an uh a hammer to the face of
the narrative machine i was i mean i
don't know if it's just because i'm like
pretty black-pilled about all of it but
i was very surprised that he like just
because the language was so vague and
done in such a way like without naming
him at all uh when even she even says
like uh as a when she talks about
domestic violence she doesn't infer him
specifically like uh mary on the show
even positive she's like she could be
just saying what if she's just a
spokesperson for domestic violence not
necessarily somebody who has actually
had you know gone through domestic
violence i said yeah but who actually
does that who becomes a spokesperson for
something they didn't actually
experience right i'm curious
did anybody here know about this before
this defamation case came to negative oh
yeah yeah yeah you did oh i remember
when they published this story and it
was like who is she talking about
they're like she was obviously talking
about johnny depp
then when he when he got booted from
pirates and what he got booted from
dumbledore yeah
from harry potter yeah well yeah from
fantastic beasts to find them that was
the one that i think is actually worse
but that they did him a favor to be
honest because it will be something yes
yes which is obviously maybe it would
have been good if johnny doubles in it
you know yeah yeah
there's no possible way
i'm good that was one of those things
where i was like that one felt more
realistic to me because that was dealing
with jk rowling who's a main producer
and writer on those movies which is
another reason because she can write
books she's not very she's not very good
at writing scripts that's uh yeah it's a
completely separate skill so but it's um
it's one of those things where she knows
what that's like to to deal with people
defaming her uh and saying stuff about
her beliefs so to have that come out and
have her not support him that felt more
uh
more tangible to me than the the stuff
about pirates this was three and a half
years ago she wrote this op-ed i spoke
up against sexual violence and faced our
culture's wrath that has to change and
it was not even drafted by her no this
is this is what the what the reality of
this country is these big machines these
the corporate press these big
non-profits these big ngos it's it's
fabricated it's a narrative machine
they're not they're not telling you
about reality it's completely
inauthentic she also never uh paid off
the she pledged the money from the from
her divorce settlement to
uh both the aclu and then what was the
other one it was a a hospital like a los
angeles children's hospital and she uh
said that she donated it but she did not
donate it she pledged the money and then
blamed johnny depp for saying well
you're suing me how can i give them the
money now because uh
i have to pay i may have to pay you back
so it's uh uh did you did anybody read
her um press release after
no it pulled it out it's it's it's where
it's on our instagram right now uh yeah
uh hannah claire sends it to me earlier
yeah
ridiculous
the gas lighting is real it's really bad
yep oh this is too long i don't care
about what she has to say
i mean i don't either that's fair um
here's what here's what's better in a
story from the babylon bee uncanceled
amber heard hired by the daily wire
good on you ben shapiro good on you
her and gina carrano can make a buddy
cop comedy oh my god this is this thing
the babylon b was brilliant amber heard
hired by the daily wire a brilliant move
from co-ceo jeremy boring on that one uh
so amber heard wrote the disappointment
i feel today is beyond words i'm
heartbroken that the mountain of
evidence still wasn't enough to stand up
to this disproportionate power influence
and sway of my ex-husband i'm even more
disappointed with what it this verdict
means for other women it is a setback
they're they're i'm seeing a bunch of
progressives on twitter
and they're like
their audience is angry at this verdict
like they wanted johnny depp to lose
well you know what i think is actually
more damaging to women who are victims
of
abuse making dishonest claims about
things right that's all yeah that's
right the one thing you'll always hear
in stories like this is that when you
lie and make false accusations you're
making it harder for actual victims and
i'm like yeah we know that look people
who lie are bad people you know that's
like the cliched response hey amber
heard your garbage your garbage yeah my
point is that i mean look to
to pretend to care about a group of
people that you are allegedly pretending
to be one of as an imposter so you can
sort of use uh whatever social capital
you think being a victim will get you as
a porn like you don't actually care they
were like a couple alcoholic cokeheads
that beat the hell out of each other i
mean they both deserve nothing adam in
my opinion i guess they're both they
both won the lawsuit for the other one
got a counter suit so she sued johnny
for a couple million bucks johnny got 10
out of her or 13 out of her well he won
the most of it because she's worth more
yeah because men get paid more than
women
maybe i don't know enough about this but
it seemed like he was trying to prove a
negative like what it seemed like this
trial proved was that both of them are
blackout crazy people like am i wrong in
that no that's that's what i think
that's what i got from it yeah but how
do you defame her so like i mean i guess
he did in that one count but she writes
an article yeah you know what i mean
well but how like you can you can be a
crackpot blackout drunk just don't go
publish it in the washington post the
number one conclusion we seem to come
through is that they were just really
bad for each other like their behavior
was in general just very
self-destructive to one another the
problem with that is is though uh we
read we covered a story yesterday where
the media basically says if you don't
believe her you're bullying her and that
um and the the writer posits that uh
mutual abuse is fake that there's no
such thing as mutual abuse in a
relationship because of power dynamics
it always comes back to power dynamics
when they're discussing this stuff
communication that's a yes and they
actually make a point to talk about like
we can talk about uh you know like how
false accusations are extremely rare and
they you know they link your articles
like what you're supposed to go to and
it's two articles about kavanaugh
[Laughter]
i was like i was like this is beyond
parody like the it's it's like so they
don't actually like you expect it to be
like some type of yougov statistics or
something that says yes it is in fact
rare for people to falsely falsely
accuse someone they always just fall
back on communism on well he had more
power that's why i lost that's what she
says in her thing the disproportionate
power influence and sway of my
ex-husband it's like dude well you did
wrong you got called out stop crying i
don't know man johnny depp does control
the courts that's true yeah yeah people
don't people don't realize that when
they keep putting george soros at the
top it's actually johnny's actually
johnny
johnny depp can play george soros in the
george soros biopic when that eventually
doesn't get made a lot of people like to
talk about the shadow government what
they don't understand is that there is a
forward-facing government that
masquerades as
a court jester and so you know the
gesture is right there the whole time
you think there's a shadow government it
was a jester pulling the strings right
in front of you see my problem with all
this is i don't think it's actually
going to change anything for society a
lot of people see this as a commentary
on the you know the relationships
between men and women how that's going
to change i said no this is just further
proof that we as a society are still
obsessed with celebrities and he has the
money to fight a 50 million defamation
lawsuit if this happens to just some
regular dude on the street who gets
defamed he doesn't have the money to
fight this in court it just it ends up
the same way i don't actually think it
changes anything long term maybe
well we live in a caste system yep uh
it's you know i feel like when this
country is founded it's very
meritocratic because a bunch of people
land on barren shores and it's like good
luck and then some of them are like well
we can steal from the native americans
others were like we can work with the
native americans and others were like
guess i'll die i guess many were like
i'll survive and you know but but that
meritocracy was was all that mattered so
if you had problems you just sought to
solve it you tried to figure it out now
that we have big cities and people
aren't moving around anymore we've
become much less meritocratic now you
have people who are born rich stay rich
who can wield influence laws get crafted
around this and you end up with regular
people like cnn goes after that guy who
makes a meme yeah so some some like dock
worker who or some warehouse worker who
posted an email at nancy pelosi they go
after him he can't do anything about it
there was the one it was like the wwe
meme of like the guy like powerbombing
like the the cnn logo or something like
that and they were like we'll reveal his
name unless he promises never to post a
meme again
yeah exactly well they'll sit there and
do something like you know destroy a
teenager's life over a completely
fabricated story and repeat that he's
some kind of white supremacist who's
harassing a native american who was a
veteran
when none of it's true and also tell the
entire country where the kid went to
school while doing it while inciting
hatred against them then someone posts a
meme poking fun at them and they go i'm
in danger
so i don't mean to say in the most
extreme case cast system what i mean to
say is we're we're growing to this point
where you have people who are just third
generation wealthy they can afford big
lawyers they just
it's remarkable how
you know i've met people who are just
rich because their families were rich
and they buy things from each other with
insane amounts of money like i i would
be like you bought lotion for 50 bucks
why and they're like that's really good
and i'm like
you get the jergens from from walmart i
don't understand like why you would do
that and they're like i don't know but
then their friend
makes the lotion and sells it for 50
bucks and i'm like when you're in that
that community you just have all of this
money i guess from whatever and tim i
told you that lotion helps rejuvenate me
you do it i think this subtree thank you
very much
but you don't got to buy the fake weird
crazy expensive my point ultimately is
we're moving that direction i do think
we're still it's it's not like
completely a cast system you can move up
the the class system but it really is
coming to that point where we have seen
so many people defamed i mean
james o'keefe may be one of the most
defamed people
and he has to fight tooth and nail and
ask people to help support him to win
these lawsuits which he does yeah johnny
depp is just ultra rich and he's like
jamming out in the uk like whatever and
then he wins
when you've got that kind of fu money
you just write a blank check to a lawyer
and say win for me and then you leave
yeah i just want to be wealthy enough
that a false accusation against me won't
be able to stick yeah
even if he had lost i mean it's one of
those things where because he had won
the court of public opinion so handily
like say he loses but he has his
reputation back he can make that up in
money in roles in no time and pay off
that 100 million lawsuit if that had
been the way this had gone but i think
he would have ended up winning either
way because his reputation is now at the
very least he's employable again by big
studios he'll be able to make more money
again and that's just proof that uh it
keeps going where does it go from here
though like does he get a career back
because again
for me personally i didn't know anything
about this until the lawsuit i think
that's a lot of america just was like
holy cow johnny depp oh i don't know man
really he got booted from harry potter
and from pirates of the caribbean yeah
there's people in the know though i'm
talking about like the wider school and
i don't know maybe regular people know
about their entertainment they so like
if you if you go to somebody and you say
do you know who hamilton was they might
be like uh
maybe yeah you know johnny depp is like
of course yeah well yeah but i still
never heard of this all i know now is
like holy cow i know johnny depp is uh
has some
interesting problems uh and i didn't
know that before and so now i'm
wondering how does he go think about
this too like
you have a normal married couple that
divorces and the wife goes around
defaming the husband what does he do
about it well she told 15 people
their inner circle now you know he loses
some of his friends and then he moves on
and then she moves on in this weird
world of celebrity and wealth she
publishes an op-ed in the washington
post drafted by a lawyer for the aclu
they're both extremely wealthy
celebrities so this crazy cultural event
happens
yeah it's just weird
you know
yeah it was like uh where was the elaine
maxwell trial why was that not televised
i know like this is
this is the funniest thing about it we
have two celebrities wagging their
fingers at each other and everyone's
glued to it lawn crime network i think
had 150 000 people watching the verdict
get read i think it was under 50 it was
more than way more than a couple million
million no live clear no not like
no uh collective views
i was watching at 500 000 people
watching okay five hundred thousand yeah
yeah yeah it was like think
like no one's allowed in you can't know
about this like she's convicted of
trafficking miners to a bunch who know
who knows we don't know anybody no
customers are gone and uh and that's
just like
i mean for i mean epstein himself
like
we got questions about what happened in
that jail cell is gone but johnny depp
top of the hour headline headline
headline bread and circus you know that
that roman tactic to keep the population
uh subdued yeah
so here's what i want to point out
at a time
when uh we've got this story from the
daily from the daily mail and i can't
show you the headline because uh youtube
might take it down
hunter biden's laptop was was leaked you
know and so there's new information
coming out about the things he was doing
i just find it funny that on on this day
something really really bad comes out
it's also the day we get the the uh the
verdict in the trial for johnny depp and
amber hurt i'm not saying this
conspiracy i'm just saying
what a distraction what did you say
bread in circuses
hunter biden
was searching for milf crack cocaine
adult content wow i just thought that
was funny because it's like well you
know he's into it right he's looking for
someone who's just like him
he was looking for lone no no get this
got this he was looking up adult content
on pornhub lonely widow
that is dark
his brother's widow and so he's like i'm
into this yeah and he's looking it up
that's creepy but here's the craziest
thing
here's what they say there's an image
that says dad on 2018 1022 and it's a
link to pornhub premium sent to dad
who is hunter biden's dad
joe biden here's what they say though
imessage records appear to show hunter
sent a link to a pornhub page to a phone
number he had saved in his context book
as dad on october 22nd 2018 however
other texts show he and joe biden used
each other's phone numbers at various
times so it is unclear whether the
president was using that number at the
time how does it even work daily mail
you realize that also means it could
have been joe sending it to his son
it could have been joe sending it to
himself joe biden being like oh this is
a really good video got me off i'm gonna
i'm gonna save this one for later by
sending it to myself at least he paid
for premium
yeah
yeah you don't want to get the cheap
stuff huh here's the craziest thing
about this is yo look i mentioned this
in the intro to the to the show i don't
care if hunter bion wants to do weird
stuff you know everybody's everyone
there's the meme where it's like the
person's dying and they're like delete
my search history because everybody's
you know searched for weird things
they'd be embarrassed by
if hunter biden wants to watch lonely
widows okay dude that's your thing
but if joe biden is using the same phone
number as hunter then how do we know how
do we differentiate between the business
dealings of hunter biden and joe biden
this sounds to me like
just evidence on top of evidence that
joe biden was using his son as a proxy
to do deals on the side while he was
you know influential in government
vice president or otherwise did you see
this email there's a story that came out
today about an email sent between james
biden and joe or and hunter biden did
you see this i think this is part of
this like drop
in an email james told hunter him hunter
you quote you need to call me now dot
dot dot just got off the phone with your
father we have the two biggest days of
our business life in front of us five or
six or seven exclamation points
we must be smart and everything or
everything goes up in smoke please call
me you must all caps remain calm timing
could not be worse common measured
paybacks can come later
so we have this right here
what is this what is this in reference
to like what are they doing i just i
don't know i i let me let me read this
as quote james and hunter biden were in
the midst of a lucrative deal with
chinese executives at the time while joe
biden was out of public service for the
first time in nearly half a century
having left the vice presidency a few
months earlier hunter biden turned to
his uncle at least as much as to his
famous father for emotional support
hunter also relied upon james biden who
goes by jim and is known as jimmy within
the family on matters of dollars and
cents within days of that exchange
hunter received another email from his
uncle urging him to take advantage of a
financial opportunity related to joe
biden
right so i mean we can all laugh at the
ridiculous
and deeply personal photos of of hunter
biden gross you know him his crack
addiction and his illicit activities and
all that stuff but i when they said that
they shared phone numbers right away i
was like yo
are we all gonna laugh that he sent this
link or are we gonna recognize this
appears to be evidence that they were
using communication platforms
interchangeably they were sharing bank
accounts
joe was doing the illicit dealings it's
not hunter biden it's joe biden who's
doing it hmm
well i can't think of any other reason
for them to share a phone number surely
they have the funds to both afford
separate is that a plausible deniability
thing maybe i don't know is that it that
joe was doing some work he's like oh
yeah hunter also uses this it probably
wouldn't be for you or i or any person
of normal means who was committing that
kind of a crime right
yeah allegedly committing that crime of
a crime right people don't share cell
phone numbers with other people that's
insane you might have a family plan with
multiple numbers on the plan the only
reason you would use the same number as
someone else is to obfuscate it i can't
why else would you they they're filthy
rich they don't need it
for money they don't need it we can we
can take it on its surface and just be
like hunter biden sent his dad
porn yeah that's what i think happened
so
maybe unit i think
let's take a look at what's going on
with this guy hunter biden
uh his dad sniffs little kids
consistently his dad talks about how
when he was younger the little kids were
rubbing my legs what did he say uh
sheamus oh the hairy legs i got a hairy
lighter the kids would rub them yeah so
here's a guy we've seen
grab women and sniff them grab children
grope children
here's a guy that's been accused by tara
reed of
unspeakable acts
and then you take a look at hunter biden
sexually depraved
crack addict i'm wondering like how does
someone who's brought up in this like
privileged family turn to this kind of
life
maybe
something a deep trauma from his past
made him turn to drugs to escape
maybe he's
gone through so why would he be sending
his dad porn
maybe his dad was abusing him and that's
why they share phone numbers and send or
he sends adult content to his dad
because they had an inappropriate
relationship when he was younger i'm not
saying it's a fact i'm not saying i have
evidence i'm saying i look at this stuff
and what i see is i'd be willing to make
the bet i'm like this guy's got deep
sexual problems you know i'm looking up
hunter's mom and brother died in a car
accident and he was actually in the car
with them
1972. so hunter that might have just
destroyed his mind but when you add into
the fact that uh their dad his dad
sniffs little girls and and gropes
children even little boys and kisses
them i'm like guitar right
tara reed accusations are unconscionable
it's unconscionable that it wouldn't be
investigated that right before he's
running for office a girl comes like he
pushed me up against the wall and fill
in the blanks look it up it's disgusting
i i just want to i just want to stress i
mean we all have seen the videos of of
joe biden groping and kissing little
kids what's the one with the redhead
girl who's like she's like shirking away
from him and looking at him all awkward
there's like whole super there's like
super cuts
like grab a little boy's head and lifts
it up and pulls him in and kisses him
there's like
didn't he he kissed his granddaughter on
the lips didn't he i believe so yeah was
that that's that's something that
happened right yeah i remember that but
recently yeah also like it's like it's
because he's older it's like it's just
it was a different time when he was when
he was younger it's it's totally normal
it was back when like humphrey bogart
would backhand women on camera and it
was cool in movies that was like that
was in the 50s yeah it wasn't like the
40s no i mean i don't i don't care if
that's true the new york post ran the
story in 2020 joe biden kisses
granddaughter on the lips during iowa
rally i mean it is shocking enough that
they're like this is a story and they
show images of him kissing his
granddaughter on the lips
okay
in fairness is there an actual video of
this because
i could oh there is because i could see
somebody turning a cheek on accident the
wrong way and you get that photo again
i'm not saying that's what happened both
puckering yeah you're right okay that
looks weird but i mean it's family you
know sometimes you you kiss family
members on the mouth and it's just like
a i've seen that happen before um
so but it's when it's the girls that
aren't his like the
his buddy's daughter that's like trying
to get out of the way when he's grabbing
at her and like there's a camera the
picture's taken you're like
then you have to ask the question is it
better or worse when he's not related to
them because that's a slippery slope to
go down too i i have no doubt that uh
that hunter was deeply abused like i've
thought that for a really really long
time seeing his acting out in his
behavior this is not the okay so the
drugs i understand a lot of rich kids
get into a lot of
um really distasteful drug practices but
his his level of acting out is very much
a case of like actual abuse and for that
i do feel bad for him and the way i feel
like his dad used him for um business
deals what are you laughing look at this
fact check from the ap
photo shows biden kissing his
granddaughter not a 15 year old oh
that's
better oh that's way better
she was 19. oh he's kissing his ground
out on the lips that's totally fine
imagine having to type that like working
for the ap on the lips
back check do you think they believed
that like whoever wrote this do you
think they believed that when they were
typing it they were like oh no this is
actually this is totally different
totally this is a bait and switch
someone was like you know you know the
meme where it's if you ever want to get
the answer to a question just post the
wrong answer and then someone
will be along the corrections
somebody was like i know that if i share
the image of biden kissing his
granddaughter the media will ignore it
so if i post the wrong thing they'll be
forced to love it
i just typed in biden smelling girl into
the search engine you should do the same
no
if you want to confirm what we're
talking about don't take my word for it
type biden smelling girl into the search
engine turn off the wi-fi if you're
doing that yeah i think he abused this
kid man well i think that's why hunter's
so messed up i did i just looked at the
math hunter was two when his when he was
in the car accident with his mom and
brother that died so
it's tough to say i mean
i don't know that would that would make
anyone i would imagine would be would
make sense i don't know
knowing that i'm not saying again
i know for a fact i'm just saying when i
look at someone like hunter biden who's
doing all these drugs who's really
messed up and sending his dad porn i'm
like ah sounds like his creepy dad who
sniffs children gropes them was probably
doing the same to his son i think they
both like porn and they both know they
both like porn it sounds to me like his
dad made it normal to share porn with
his son which is in itself disturbing
like when did that start i don't view
that as being i personally do not view
that as being normal i don't view that
as being wholesome in any way that's
disgusting
i don't know it does kind of seem like
one of those things where like when you
when you've uh been uh a drug addict for
that long and especially if your family
doesn't discipline you when you're
younger and you don't find a way to like
get clean or get better and your brain
just gets more and more adult and
there's no repercussions for your
actions uh it's like escalating and
getting worse and getting worse and it's
just more noticeable to us because it's
such a prominent family
but i just don't know if uh i would
expect anything more if he didn't take
the i don't know if he's clean now if
he's doing better now but it's just not
something that i i have a hard time
believing that he'd be able to get clean
without help and his dad's clearly not
helping him his family's too worried
about their public image that they're
having their uh
his messages and his laptop deleted and
uh you know kept out of the public
record they don't have time to worry
about how his actual health is
you know what though
the biden family they probably enjoy
delicious meals of crab from delaware
excellent crabbing country
so out in maryland we have excellent
crab cream of crab soup that's right
very wholesome for the family that
sounds delicious yeah it's really good
hungry thanks yeah i went to a
restaurant and they had uh lobster and
crab
really yeah it's very great is this a
strange segue where are we yeah
what are we doing here nothing just
complete
you know we're talking about hunter
biden growing up and i'm like they're in
delaware or whatever and i'm like
they're probably eating a lot of crab
hey you know what's in there go to the
restaurants like everything's scripted i
think one thing we didn't get to show is
the the pictures from that what was it
the daily mail article yeah i'm not
showing those no we can't show them but
i mean if you wonder if hunter's doing
okay now look at that article and look
at those pictures and that will answer
the question for you i know how old the
pictures are but he does not look like
he's doing good let's let's let's uh so
look joe biden's been miserable let's
talk about the story real quick we got
this from timcast.com
kentucky democrat senate candidate wears
noose in new campaign ad criticizing
senator rand paul
in case you're wondering how democrats
are doing you need to look at this image
joe biden's doing miserably it is they
they are they need a hail mary desperate
pass to try and pull this off
and so i we end up getting this ad where
an absolutely
desperate democrat candidate they know
they're losing
now i don't know what's going to happen
for all we know democrats end up winning
sure fine whatever the red wave is
what's being predicted because
republicans are up in the generic ballot
this guy
made a campaign ad with a noose around
his own neck
and progressives are calling it
bold
what courageous and i'm like well that
is true you gotta have balls of steel to
make a campaign but when i saw this i
was just like it was kind of a moment of
realization for me
for the first it's the craziest
political ad i've ever i've seen in my
lifetime unless i'm forgetting something
which is possible there was another one
where they were like running people down
in manga trucks or something
that was also crazy but you know before
like growing up the campaign ads were
like my opponent wants to raise taxes
and he voted no on the safer schools act
now it's a guy he puts a news from his
neck and he's like look what they've
done to me
wow he put this noose around my neck and
said this is mega
paul poured country on me outside of
subway that's right the media is like
rand what do you have to say for
yourself
and he's like i didn't do it and they're
like he's lying he admits it i i never
did that like well that's what you would
say if you did it you did it i do agree
i've never seen an ad where they make
themselves the victim when someone's
running for office and it's like look
how badly i've been treated vote vote
for me that's also a very good point
that's such a bizarre strategy to be
like i
am a victim it's like
we were supposed to like leaders what is
this i got i do have to point out yes i
did not remember this one virginia ad
features minority kids chased by truck
with gillespie sticker and confederate
flag
yeah this is just the scare tactics
it's like they're writing fanfics they
are they are see but see the difference
is this is a normal ad the news
no yeah we'll play it
like what is this what does this white
do the confederate flag doing they made
sure he turned his head slowly though
he's running down minority kids what
does it look like
but i don't think he actually does
anything to the kids he doesn't well
whoever whatever politician this was
probably intervened before he got a
chance to do so all right but he did i
actually know
i actually think this is a really good
commercial
run run run the truck is coming up girl
oh no
what's it gonna do what's it yeah like
what what is it what does the guy even
do oh no no not the gas and flag
ah he's gonna run him over oh is this a
nightmare how did it become night so
fast
this is actually i think this is a good
commercial i know the psa is like maybe
stop fabricating fake hate crimes and
scaring the crap out of your children
exactly it's a good idea these kids are
having nightmares because you scream in
their faces about things they don't got
to be worrying about for the most part
the kim klasik ads were really good that
she had those were good yeah that was a
good example of high production value uh
but focusing on whatever issues she
wanted to talk about in the community
you know walking the streets of
baltimore i just want to point out they
took the tweet
they took that unbelievably banal
histrionic dramatic left-wing tweet that
we see every couple months and made a
commercial the my kid said to me i'm
scared because republican is gonna do x
it's like your kid didn't say that
you're making this up what's wrong with
you they took they took that and they
made it a commercial do you remember the
the lincoln is it the lincoln project
was doing a project their commercial
that they had where it was like four
more years and i didn't know you could
serve three terms
you remember that commercial yeah
oh my goodness no it was uh it was um
it was donald trump in a pickup truck
chasing down abe lincoln probably yeah
he hates america see but the thing about
these commercials is they're
i don't i don't want to give them any
sort of gravitas but at least they're
legit the thing with the noose is just a
publicity stunt yeah this guy's running
in kentucky against rand paul he knows
he's not going to win he's trying to get
twitter followers to parlay that into a
job at msnbc
that's his goal that's what a lot of it
always feels like to me is that they're
looking they know they're not going to
win especially in like specific
districts yeah he's trying to get
attention so that he can make his next
career move well he clearly literally
wants victim points by actually putting
a noose around his neck like i can't
think of a more direct parallel to being
like oh look at me i'm a victim give me
a job at msnbc
oh man we gotta wait
oh yeah blow this one up
don't let the bed bugs bite
look at that color scheme it's so dark
this is that meme where the kids like
mommy donald trump is a fascist
it's like a red white like an american
flag blanket
you asked me to wake you and tell you
what happened in the election
oh no he did not yes he did yes he did
the kid definitely did that no school
tomorrow
look
oh my gosh
what just one second all right just
besides everything that is obviously
wrong with this
if he was running for president after he
had already served two terms
why would the kid be confused about the
possibility of him winning
the idea that you can only have two
terms is not voter enforced it's not
like we let them run again and then the
american people don't know he had two
terms we're not voting but only after he
wins exactly oh no yeah but it's
literally election night
she says donald trump might win and he
goes wake me up when we find out and
then she wakes up and goes but i thought
you could only serve two terms why did
you ask then why did you ask
making me get up in the middle tonight
to tell you about something you didn't
even know about it uh son we've been
over this in some insane fascistic way
that the lincoln project dreamed up he
changed the law that's why he was
running again that's why there was the
election i gotta i gotta give a shout
out because this ad was actually like it
may as well have been a trump ad like an
ad for trump yeah dude and so yeah
like after all the trump supporters were
like yeah
like this is hilarious it's got more
play i think than any it got more so
and then it just goes to infinity and
they wrote articles where they were like
trump supporters want trump to be
president for life so they're they're
like they're like
trump would be president for more than
two terms and you know who i love fdr
best president we ever had we need
someone like him
they worship the man he served four
terms as president by the way fdr before
the 22nd amendment was passed but he
died shortly into his form dudes served
so many terms they had to pass an
amendment
no more if you do so much of something
that someone has to pass a
constitutional amendment you are a
problem
they say that fdr was the most fascist
president he and woodrow wilson i don't
want to derail
no yeah that they were
bad
two terms you think that's good
president should be able to serve
one term one six year term one six year
term yeah think about it i mean i'm not
entirely fully settled on this i just
think you know in terms of the president
having to run for re-election
when you get into the last two years of
their four-year term it turns into silly
season right and people start cutting
checks for
okay who do what vote do i need okay i
need minorities in wisconsin wisconsin
what do they need and then you federal
money goes to them like that like you
get rid of that with one six-year
presidential term now that that is
assuming that i believe the president
should have as much power as he does
which i do not or she does
uh so you know that's really insightful
it's very muddling to have a president
running for office and trying to be the
president yeah
well and it i feel like i don't know
that doesn't seem crazy one six year
term like it seems like a yeah
good time it's a good compromise i think
for one four-year term is just not
enough well one four-year term is your
your
i don't know i can be swayed
yeah things happen fast now they happen
a lot faster than they used to
information travels a lot faster
well then they push stuff off to set
like they start pushing stuff off on
their on like what they plan to get done
right so they're like oh well we'll
focus on that for the second term so
they start pushing stuff on the agenda
off until term two you know under the
context that they're actually going to
win so if you give them one six year
term that forces them to do all that
they want to work on right then and then
but then how do you talk about like
congress in the senate like would that
be along the same lines as like uh
uh
you know
deep into the weeds there
so this this this ad the good night
america thing was put up on october 22nd
2020. i just think it's funny that
they
they make this ad
and in 2019 we had the best numbers of
our lives in the economy
and so the worst thing they could think
of was that trump would just win again
because they had no real argument
against him
i i i honestly you'd ask people like
okay what don't you like about trump and
they'd be like he's a fascist or
whatever they wouldn't give you a real
reason that's why that i think they made
the sad because they were like people
don't know why they hate trump
they just want him to go away
and they don't want him to go away
because people are screaming in their
ears in the media
so they voted for a guy who tanked the
economy
his son
is driving gas prices through the roof
apparently is is conversing on um the
finer links to porn with his child
just i mean the apple doesn't fall far
from the tree and so now here we are
the average person i mean man
spending like what you're gonna spend
like 70-100 bucks to fill up your gas
tank but hey
three three terms of trump oh
that would have been the worst right
there was uh like literally the other
day i was scrolling instagram and i had
three stories in a row where it was like
friends posting their gas like filling
up their gas tank where it's like going
over eighty dollars and says thanks joe
biden and like all three of them were
like like one had like a sticker on it
one said thanks joe biden the other one
just was like a middle finger and it's
just all people focusing on the fact
that they can't afford to drive anymore
i swear i think it's the federal reserve
has been planning to crash this for a
while and they're blaming trump and
biden and they're making us blame trump
and biden and this has just been a
fascist move since they know it was
falling apart who's blaming trump
well some people some people they just
hate him and but it's these guys are not
the ones that caused this this is like
banking cartels let's talk about i think
the the uh
the q and on people who think he had a
third term are blaming him they're like
why is he letting this happen yeah that
was that was actually one of the things
i will give um
that was that guy's name jordan clepper
is that his name
he he's he talks to a q a guy and he's
like so you think trump is really the
president he's like yes he is he's like
why is he making gas prices so high and
the guy's like no that's joe biden he's
like but you said that trump was
president i'm like yeah okay those
people but let's talk about what's gonna
happen in november so joe rogan on his
show said he's a liberal jane kuger of
the young turks responds he says it's
amazing how unaware people are joe rogan
just said quote i'm so liberal like i
talk about it all the time like i am not
a conservative based on what all he's
done for the past two years is extreme
right-wing propaganda but in his mind
he's still a compassionate liberal i
can't name a single thing rogan was in
the news for in the last two years that
was a left-wing position i can't name a
single thing he has criticized the right
wing for he still promotes lunatic right
winger alex jones and in his mind he's
on the left hilarious and ridiculous
hold on can i say that yes [ __ ] there's
a reason for that because the status quo
within the dominant media culture is
that you do not get to say things that
are right leaning so of course he's not
going to be in the news for any of his
left wing that's not true though you
don't get in trouble for that's not true
joe was in the news for tons of
left-wing stuff supporting bernie
sanders supporting andrew yang and
supporting universal basic income
numerous times the issue is that jenk
doesn't actually read the news he hears
the news from someone else and so when
they're like did you hear joe rogan said
a naughty word he goes that's the news
when you actually go to the news
websites you're like oh joe rogan's
promoting universal basic income which
is almost socialism and he says not
promoting left-wing ideas well he
doesn't fair enough but well in fair
enough but also the stories that have
been the biggest the ones that have been
the most controversial and the ones that
have resulted in people coming after him
and thus became giant stories were all
the ones where you had right-wing
perspectives because those are the ones
you are not allowed to have but it's
it's the elon me
it's the elon meme of like the left has
gone so much further to the left the
people and
yeah the joe rogans of the world who
kind of just stayed put the joe rogans
the bill mars are kind of like no you
guys changed a lot and so in his mind i
can see him still thinking that he's a i
don't know if he would call himself a
progressive but liberal minded i could
say
i say it all the time people who don't
read the news versus people who who do
their research yeah because granted like
reading the news might not inform you
this is an example of he doesn't say
that rogan has not said a left-wing view
he says i can't name one because he
hasn't been following him he hasn't been
listening to him exactly the point so
you see you see jankuger he comes out
and he criticizes joe rogan saying he's
only spewing right-wing propaganda fast
company wrote an article a couple weeks
ago saying why you need to be aware of
right-wing comedy like joe rogan or
something like that no i'm not i'll pull
up a second
if you don't actually investigate if you
don't actually listen to people and you
just believe the narrative machine well
then of course jenk is surprised by this
do you think the news
was ever has gotten more dishonest or it
was always this dishonest always always
yeah they've just become more overt in
certain ways and they're also different
audiences they've decided to pander to
that have made it more obvious to us
that they're decisions
take a look at this from fast company
why you need to take right-wing comedy
seriously from joe rogan to the babylon
b to stephen crowder the new book that's
not funny deconstructs their appeal and
why it matters
yo joe rogan was a famous comedian 20
years ago like what do you mean right
wing he was on news radio he's hilarious
he's got netflix special he does stand
up he's on fear factor he's not a right
wing guy he's never been if you can't
realize that this mainstream sitcom
comedian hosting these shows who is a
liberal if you if you if you can't see
that you've moved on this one
i i don't i don't know i don't know how
he can help you do you think it's a
publicity thing like do you think jake
is trying to create controversy with the
biggest podcast in the world
to
i do i don't think so
like he's not helping people with that
tweet he's just getting it that's what
i'm saying no i think he was trending on
twitter today i think he listen
if you live in a world where you only
hear from the establishment machine and
you think joe rogan is right wing
because you don't actually investigate
anything he said
you're going to get frustrated you're
going to get angry
that anger that we feel about joe biden
doing illicit business dealings with
ukraine and china through his son about
the quid pro quo with the with the
prosecutor in ukraine with the president
fire the prosecutor you're not getting
the billion dollars she had no authority
to do i get angry because there's no
accountability of course russiagate i
get angry there's no accountability so i
fight for that
you know you know what you know what
we've investigated these stories i've
looked up a bunch of facts i've seen
sworn affidavits on the the ukraine
biden scandal and so i say
i believe beyond a reasonable doubt that
there was illicit business dealings here
in order for there to be accountability
we now need a legitimate investigation
to determine that but i am angry because
it's not happening there is actual
probable cause
joe biden had no authority to do that he
did it he admitted it on camera the
prosecutor signed a sworn affidavit
saying he did it courts ruled ukraine
were meddling all of that stuff and i
say i want accountability jankuger hears
narrative garbage nonsense without facts
checking and says joe biden is right
wing and he's genuinely angry about it
oh you said joe biden joe rogan joe
rogan
but you know maybe genuine joe biden you
know i think he's i think i think jenk
you know what i think happens is he
lives in this narrative world of the
corporate press
and the world keeps the ground keeps
dropping out beneath his feet like when
when trump won
everyone's seen that compilation video
of the young turks losing it
because they they trump broke them they
couldn't believe it they had been told
over and over again what was true and
what was going to happen i got to talk
to chank about or jank rather sorry jank
um about hillary's emails when that
dropped and they went to wikileaks like
what did that cause i remember him
talking about it or at least
acknowledging it and being like well the
dnc is complete trash but like where is
he where where why is he still not like
okay let's go deep on the
military-industrial complex now instead
he's like still hung up on the
partisanship it's tribalism versus
principle
a principled person says you know i'm
not a fan of the republicans but hey if
they're destroying public records trump
was accused of something similar with
cell phones or whatever i'm like yeah we
should we should know about that that's
that's we you know we need to hear about
that
it doesn't happen when you you've got
the tribal side that says we ignore what
our side does we only care if your side
does it well that doesn't help your side
like making bad faith arguments or
completely ignoring
things doesn't help you
well maybe i think what we're seeing now
is that the the two factions are
increasingly becoming npcs versus
player characters so that's why i say
the uninitiated versus the discerning
people who see the news and say i don't
know if i believe that i'm gonna fact
check it versus people who are like wow
that's true they lied to me a hundred
times but i'll believe it this time
and then you end up fighting over it i
mean look i gotta tell you when we we
bring up
the left says the exact same things
about the right the right says about the
left and it's like who's right and i've
heard this from these politically
uninitiated people who are like i'm not
you know on the left but the right says
the exact same thing and you got no no
no no no justice millet
obviously was a hoax covington kids hoax
hands up don't shoot hoax russia gate
ukraine gate we go through the list all
the time at a certain point you might be
like huh the things the left believes
tend to be false
how about that
and then maybe then you can be like
maybe there's a reason why politically
homeless post liberals moderates
libertarians and conservatives all
occupy a similar space maybe there's a
reason christian conservative and
traditional liberal can sit in a room
and agree and make jokes with each other
because we know for the most part
what is true and what isn't they don't
they don't understand so everyone must
be far right even joe rogan joe rogan
has been pro universal basic income let
me tell you joe rogan wants the
government to issue blank blanket checks
to all people to give them cash to live
off of and bro if that is right wing
then i don't know what left left-wing
even is also i don't think you can be in
favor of legal abortion and be
considered a conservative i'm sorry
and like he doesn't call himself one but
they do it's like that's not a
conservative position at all like if
anything's not conservative it's that
well i'll tell you man it's it's like
the modern left
just says whatever the modern left says
yeah so that's why when you talk to
these people they they argue with me
these progressives tim late term
abortion never happens why are you even
talking about it and i'm like because
you just said women should be able to do
it still be able to do it well like do
you think women should be able to have
an abortion at nine months it's the
woman's choice okay well i have an issue
with that it never happens why even
bring it up because you said it should
because you're trying to pass a law to
make it happen bro
yeah there's no principle and that's
what that's what i think it ultimately
comes down to there is a great filter
happening right now in politics where
the people who don't read the news are
drifting off to the left and the people
who do who i should say the people who
don't fact check are drifting to the
left and people who do are drifting to
the right
you know not only i think a lot of the
people who don't read the news are also
being pushed to the right by people on
the left they see behaving absurdly or
also it's possible they're staying in
the same place but the left is moving so
far to the left that they seem right
wing by comparison hey look i'm going to
say it right now you know what you're
right joe rogan's right wing he is he's
right wing fast company says it so uh to
all of my friends who uh voted for joe
biden you like joe joe rogan you're
conservatives so you're all right-wing
so uh no that's true
cause they will call literally every
single person who's outside of their
bubble of maybe three percent of the
population right wing and then whenever
our country passes any kind of
legislation which is conservative they
go this is not how a representative
democracy's supposed to work well i
don't know like you spend all your time
calling 95 percent of the population
right wing so why would it be a threat
to our democracy for more right leaning
legislation to be passed
when they're saying our democracy
they're not talking about you no they
are not they're talking right now they
literally mean our right not yours this
is this is the mistake republicans often
make these progressives will say or
these media personalities it's a danger
to our democracy they're not saying you
conservative and them they're not saying
the american people they're saying it's
a threat to the cult's efforts at
building a cult democracy
yeah you know what i think having two
parties is a threat to their democracy
should just be one right it should just
be the democratic party then there'd
never be another threat to our democracy
yeah the democratic party of the
american people or the democratic
people's party of america
that's right something like that like
the people's party the democrats
represent people like the people's party
yeah the united states yeah the people's
republic
hey there you go yeah the democratic
people's republic of america yeah i
think i love it interesting wow i would
also say
i would also hazard a guess that the
average person the politically
uninitiated doesn't know that any of
those are hoaxes except for maybe the
smell that one
that right
if you pulled the average person says i
don't pay attention to politics i don't
know what's going on and probably only
because dave chappelle pointed it out uh
let me let me let me let me uh i'm going
to ask you joe bob a question yeah no
but nobody chime in this is a question
for joe bob uh-oh
how many buildings fell on 911
fell completely yeah collapsed uh
three you are correct good sir most
people don't know that now i'm not
trying to start a conversation around 9
11. i'm trying to point out that one of
the most culturally significant
historical moments and most people would
say too because they didn't actually
look into what happened but i'll tell
you this a lot of these people would say
never forget but they never learned in
the first place so
in that same line i was hanging out with
uh
a couple friends i'll be vague
and they were shocked
that
not five or six police officers died in
the j6 riots that's what they thought
right and and they were like i was like
no no there's i mean
there's some complications with
identifying what caused uh the police
officer's death i'm fuzzing up the yeah
yeah something like that but in their
mind
five or six cops were killed that day
ethan klein just tweeted to doc in
response to donald trump that uh trump
incited an instruction that killed six
people and it's like yeah what are you
talking about you're talking about like
well some some i think some some dude
fell some lady got trampled
and then actually uh babbitt i think
yeah
got shot
well i'm not saying that like
at all
lightens what happened that day i'm just
saying
factions all right which is incorrect
how many right now the daily beast has
been down ranked by newsguard they're a
fake news website now they get the red
exclamation point because they
completely fabricated or just fell for
the cal written house lies so there
there was a there were articles written
that said cal right now has killed black
people
and it's just they just made it up
that was another thing again we live in
weirdo world group of friends that i
have in in california uh thought kyle
rittenhouse shot a couple black people
okay
i understand how you would think that if
you're barely paying attention yeah you
know you were saying you get a you were
feeling anger when you thought about the
ukraine stuff with biden and like how
other people just don't get it i felt
like that about 9 11 after the buildings
came down and it was just like okay the
investigation's over nothing bad
happened it was just a couple of planes
and i was like well a couple of planes
three buildings
and no one it was like impo near
impossible to find people that actually
cared about it and i was like i went to
anger and depression so from like 2007 8
9 10 i was suicidal like
people are really they really don't care
and now i've gotten past that and i i
care i'm just gonna do what i can even
though i'm disillusioned it's the same
thing
the only thing they cared about was
adhering to the social norms and
narrative to fit in so if you said
something like hey i think we need a
better investigation into this because
like we spent more money i think on bill
clinton you know banging an intern than
we did on that and then they'd be like
what are you saying this is ridiculous
i'll sit down with some journalists and
this was in um was it 2012
when when did when did we get osama bin
laden was that 2012 i think i believe
yeah pull that one up i'm sitting with a
bunch of journalists
and uh we're going to 2011 2011. i was
at a bar in new york and then someone
was was bringing up the story and i
laughed and i said man that whole thing
played out like a bad action movie and
then this journalist gets really angry
and goes i am sick of hearing this
conspiracy about and i was like whoa
whoa
what are you talking about and he's like
you're acting like it didn't happen
you're claiming it did i was like i
didn't say that at all i said that whole
thing played out like a bad action movie
did you read the story on what happened
with like he grabbed his wife and he
didn't grab his wife and they dumped his
butt out of a helicopter and he was like
yeah and i'm like yeah it sounds like a
bad action movie and look but it
happened i was like i didn't say it
didn't dude calm down anything that
deviated from the approved norm people
just snapped they're like don't deviate
from machine
and i'm like bro think
chill
why are you getting so angry about this
this is what happens to people when
anything threatens their their
constructed world view
so what's happening now is with people
who have the ability to read information
on the internet
fact check things for themselves and be
like oh yeah look at this joe biden did
say if you don't fire the prosecutor
you're not getting a billion dollars wow
the media lied to me
the people who don't want to hear it
plug the ears and go la la la la la la
and then when you say to them they get
angry shut up shut up you're challenging
my world view brandon strzok told us the
other day
how he ended up walking away from the
democrats because someone told him that
trump never mocked a disabled reporter
and he was like yes he did we saw him do
it i see i've seen the video and he
didn't want to watch the video and so he
said okay i'm going to watch this it's
going to be obvious propaganda and he
said when he watched it it actually hurt
it it was it hurt him like he
experienced pain physically from
realizing his world view was wrong and
he couldn't deny it anymore
how how
what do you guys think of what what is
the
on a scale of one to ten throughout
history where is
politics just in general
at right now in the country what do you
mean like what is one and what is in
terms 10 being like everybody's talking
about it all the time and one is nobody
no no
we're in it that's why it seems no no i
would say somewhere between four and six
no it's just it's a ten so okay so let's
operate on that really quick maybe it's
a relativity scale maybe so like world
war ii i would have thought it was more
uh it's it's a 10 right now and i would
i say that because that doesn't mean
everyone at all times absolutely only
talks about politics obviously you know
brett talks about pop culture stuff on
pop culture crisis but what i mean is
when you see
podcasters who got started well so
let's just pretend there was an election
and let's just say one candidate got i
don't know 80 million votes and the
other candidates say got 80 million
votes how many people are there in the
united states of america three twenty
two yeah so that's about half the people
voted how many are voting age
you discount the people under eighteen
but even then like let's just say
pipe that is forty percent of people
don't vote actually i think that might
be the voting like the voting age block
no way
not obviously the
uh let's see 252 million people are
voting age
yeah okay so so two-thirds of the voting
age population i think so what is that
100 million people don't vote
yeah yeah that that's 240 million people
were eligible 66 submitted ballots
158 million that's a huge number yeah
right like and especially given the fact
that it seems like we're inundated
constantly with political discussion
political discourse whatever you want to
call it
and still
a huge percentage of people don't vote i
got an idea
here's what we do
if people don't vote
and the amount of people who don't vote
is greater than the amount of votes
for uh greater than the greatest amount
of votes for single candidate and
there's no president
perfect that's it the united states
stopped can we just stop to that part it
stops 66 it's one on hold until we can
figure out 66.1 percent of people
submitted ballots that means
didn't vote would have won
well here's another well here's what i
think we need to do we need to have a
third option on the ballot that says
literally anyone else and if you pick it
we just if it wins a random person the
population is selected and they are the
president the king of the beginning
yeah with the with the ranked choice
voting thing but not to get off no no no
uh demarchy would would be like you'd
get president you you'd get to congress
duty it's like one day you go to your
mailbox and you've got like a certified
letter and it's like you've been chosen
for congress dude you're like
i'm going to capitol hill i've been
chosen for congress
you know you're there for a couple
months that honestly would be terrible
but what i think i think what i'm trying
to get at ultimately is that there's
this huge
attempt to push people to one side or
the other by the respective sides to
pull people into their side or push
people to their side or whatever it is
that you want to call it
while in reality everything is based on
turnout
are people going to show up and are
people going to turn out in terms of
running actual campaigns
especially at the local level you don't
really care about changing the mind
about somebody who's not registered your
particular party whatever candidate
you're running you're really caring
about
turning the people out who you already
know are going to vote for you and so i
feel like that's
part of the big reason why the political
rhetoric is so heated because it's not
about convincing people
to
your ideas it's getting the people who
already agree with you to just show up
here's a fascinating thing
in order for conservatives to win more
voters they need only convince a person
to do nothing no no to search for the
information on their own
to take the initiative among upon
themselves
read the news
the left needs to strictly control the
news and make sure they don't get access
to what's really good and also what is
most important to them is flooding the
voting booths with uninformed people so
this is why you constantly see get out
and vote campaigns where some left-wing
celebrity which is to say most if not
all of them is on screen telling you
that you need to get out there and vote
because they know if somebody needs a
celebrity to tell them to vote they
don't know anything about politics and
they are therefore going to choose
whoever the democrats are putting out
that's going to backfire you're right
you're right that is absolutely
happening i think that's going to
backfire on them currently uh you've got
the border situation being what it is uh
there's the argument made that the
conservatives want the labor uh the
liberals want the votes
especially when it comes to
hispanics uh
we've seen the demographic shifting
heavily heavily towards the whole
conservative side
meaning that a bunch of liberals are
trying to depend on those votes in
coming and it's gonna backfire because i
think the left has gone so far left
you've got a family
generally heavily religious population
who they used to send get out the vote
campaigns to their community
all of a sudden realizing holy cow these
guys are way way way more left than i
want and i i honestly think it's going
to backfire yeah people are questioning
the narrative uh way more than they were
a decade ago in 2009 part of the reason
why i lost it was disillusioned with
life is because no one it seemed like
seven percent of the people cared now
it's like 20 28 27 of the people it's
enough it's enough people and those
people i used to be democrat brandon
strzok my parents they they know like
they will question nonsense they will
question the things they're told and
that's their old school liberals man
not everybody though probably more right
though when shows like this exist a lot
of people are like i watch cnn they
don't lie
do you think they do yeah
do you think that
democrats or liberals whatever i don't
like labels necessarily but do you think
the left
as a side has another barack obama
somewhere because the barack obama
yeah yeah barack obama was
whether or not you agree with his
policies
a political superstar like fantastic at
making you feel good
and like we're all saying that that's
what's driving people to the polls on
the left side of the aisle
do you think they have one of those in
the wings because we were talking about
the 2024 election downstairs and what
happens there currently i don't see a
democrat front runner yeah it wouldn't
be they need a guy unfortunately i think
society has a lot of disillusioned young
men and they're that's why they're
attracted to donald trump he's a strong
male figure michelle's great personality
wise like like great lake obama was
great but i don't know if she would
appeal to those young men which obama
did in spades oh totally the only other
one i can see is like beto o'rourke but
he's such trash these days i don't think
i could see them trying to push him
though but he's just not charismatic no
way he's also too just out there there's
too much baggage there he's so bad yeah
check us out way too many problems i got
this your tweet from david hookstead
david
is uh let's see what he's okay so you
know him yeah he says beto o'rourke says
people who currently own semi-automatic
rifles should have them confiscated 22
seconds let's let's let's hear what mr
o'rourke has to say i just took the
position that may not be politically
popular maybe two one is that not only
should no one be able to purchase an
ar-15 or an ak-47 because they're
designed to kill humans and that
high-impact high-velocity round will
just tear up everything inside you'll
bleed out before we can get you back to
life
but i don't think that the people who
have them right now in civilian use
should be able to keep them i just took
the picture now i wonder if there's more
to that but come on this is the guy who
said heck yeah we're taking your ar-15
so now apparently he's coming back out
saying he's going to confiscate your
weapons yo they line they say no one's
talking about taking your guns and
they're like oh yeah we will i wonder
what their inter internal polling shows
it shows that liberal so conservatives
are overwhelmingly pro-gun and democrats
are split so the overwhelming majority
of this country is like now we want to
keep our guns then they come out these
fake stats where they're like most
people support background checks it's
like okay yeah we have those already so
what do you mean by that and they're
like well when we ask people
they so so it's it's it's almost a
mountain bailey they'll say well no no
we mean
restricting private sales requiring
background checks there and i'm like
that's not what you asked people in the
poll
in the poll it said do you think there
should be background checks for gun
buyers and they say yes you didn't get
specific because at almost every single
point of sale there's going to be a
background check then they say no no no
we mean shut up you want a registry
that's what they want
i i just think beto wants attention like
honestly like the the stunt that he
pulled at the press conference i'm sure
you guys covered that where he walked up
and talked and like it's just a
publicity stunt and i i don't like stuff
like that being made political also just
just for the sake of being fair i also
didn't like when governor abbott used
the shooter's name immediately after it
happened i didn't like that either i
thought we were all on the same page
like we're not going to glorify these
people i want to pull up this tweet from
jonathan height because we're fans of
his assessment but he he has one of the
worst tweets i've ever seen he said the
best thing i've ever read about reducing
gun violence is this 2017 essay by nick
kristoff recently updated if we take a
public health approach modeled after
cars there is so much we can do even in
a defined country
wrong
and i'll tell you why
here's what he's proposing background
checks 22 of guns are obtained without
one and
you need a background check at any
federally licensed dealer there are some
private sales but whenever they're
talking about these these these
tragic events they were purchased
legally background checks didn't change
it safe storage trigger locks as well as
guns and ammunition stored separately
especially when children are in the
house well that's great someone kicks
your door in the middle of the night and
they're going to violate your wife and
you're like hold on i need to open the
safe with the bullets then open the safe
with the gun then load the met that then
load the the the rifle and then i can
save you honey and immunity for firearm
companies that's a subsidy to a
particular industry no it isn't it makes
no s what are we going to do if if
someone manufactures glass bottles and
then someone uses that to crack someone
over the head you see the bottle maker
it's like you're not supposed to commit
crimes protection orders
keep men who are subject to domestic
violence protection orders from having
guns we already do straw purchases we
are don't allow that ban bum stocks okay
that actually happened under trump but
that makes no sense because
full auto was never a big issue here
ban under 21s constitutional violation
ammunition checks experimentation with a
one-time background check for anybody
buying ammo we already have background
checks on people buying weapons what
would that accomplish research smart
guns researching means nothing doesn't
mean anything so this is you know for
jonathan height to say that this is go
you know even in a divided nation we can
do those things no you can't because you
have no idea what you're talking about
i'm not gonna even even pretend that i
know for the most part what i'm talking
about i'm not even an expert on guns but
i can look right away and be like you
have no idea what you're talking about
and that's the problem the ignorant
democrat voters are voting for their
feelings and they don't know anything we
demand background checks okay you win
oh you guys all right i agree you win we
have background checks now next yeah
they're like well you know these people
committing crimes are breaking every law
in order to do them do we need more laws
yes
that will do it i think that'll fix it
there was a uh marco rubio got a bunch
of heat i think in like 2015 where he
marco rubio's claimed that no recent
mass shootings would have been prevented
by gun laws um and then glenn kessler of
the washington post the fact checker
over there uh not only didn't give it
any pinocchios he gave it the rare
geppetto like yeah no he's right
that all of the the mass shootings
wouldn't
none of that unfortunately would have
been stopped
uh
choose my words carefully here they
marco rubio said that
none of those shootings would have been
stopped by any sort of gun laws and
even
the washington post said yeah no he was
right about that and the problem is what
you were saying is that people are just
ignorant on the the issue yeah like my
my biggest thing too is also just
asking questions about implementation oh
i just say what's an assault weapon well
i say that too the first thing i think
is if you ask the average democrat voter
like what they believe in ar15 is
they're going to tell you that the ar
stands for assault rifle and they're
going not going to be able to find them
to you that if they're going to think
that it's fulladdo i would guess like
most of them think that so uh shout out
to our good friend ethan klein he was
talking on h3 and he was mentioning
something about people going in front of
uh abbott's house with ar-15s and he
goes
i'm like is that what you think those
things do yeah you know
no wonder you want to ban them well so
i am as someone who went to an art
school i am an expert on people who
don't know anything about guns right now
and so i remember that that's like
embedding to research you know like
you're going it was like a case study
kind of thing yeah yeah i went
undercover thanks for doing that for us
you're welcome so i was having a
conversation with a friend
and she said to me that um
she was like well i don't think that we
should have like these semi-automatics
and i was like do you know what a
semi-automatic she's like it's
semi-fully
you pull the trigger and it sprays the
bullets and i was like holy no no no
that's not what any of that means and i
tried to explain that that was not the
case uh and and their response was to
just insist that we still didn't need to
have them
i wish i had the clip but i remember
cool person in other ways by the way but
just was out to lunch on that one i
remember watching jesse smellette is
trending
probably because of that
sorry i i introduced you he's got a new
uh show coming out on bet plus he's back
at work oh nice really yes are you
serious yeah he's he's directing and
starring in a show about um uh break
dancing or something like that something
it's like an lgbtq plus uh film that uh
be et plus no he's trending because
everyone's saying amber hurt is just
he's just it's jessie's possible i love
it
ah sorry what were you saying
oh no last week i was watching msnbc or
one of your big cable news networks
and they were talking about gun control
and like your point the both of the
anchors were like yeah we need gun
control have you ever shot a gun no i've
never shot a guy have you shot a gun no
no never i would never shoot a gun so we
have two people who have never shot a
gun talking about gun control clearly
not knowing anything about
the thing that they're trying to control
they need to learn how to control guns
those two people remember
there you go yeah i remember that
reporter who got ptsd from firing
yeah and then people were replying with
comments of like them training their
young daughters to shoot it like yeah
they're like this is actually not that
there's a video going viral of a little
girl dual wielding i don't know what
she's got 1911's and she's using two
fingers to pull the trigger and then
they're like this is child abuse look
what they're doing to that child and i'm
like well the the real problem is that
they're having her fire two handguns
simultaneously which is just terribly
inaccurate and there's no reason to do
that
um
i there's a meme i love and it said uh
actually maybe i can pull it up try and
find it i posted it on instagram it was
hilarious does jesse malette actually
have a show i i can't tell if that was i
forget what the name of the
yeah we kind of mentioned it in podluck
it's uh it's called mega country and
it's a second yeah
about a break about break dancing mega
supporters that would be that would be
fantastic who wandered the streets of
chicago at two in the morning
i think here's here's the meme i got it
says children and firearm safety
children and guns are simply a bad idea
your average firearm is too unwieldy for
a typical child to operate in a safe and
effective manner that's right children
are much better suited to crew to crew
serve weapons right the semi-stationary
characteristic of a mortar or heavy
machine gun relies less than the child's
physical strength and stamina and also
builds teamwork yeah and it shows a
little boy and little girl and shows
like a machine gun and a mortar and a
thumbs up
i actually had the thought after i don't
think i don't think that should be legal
after this texas meme or could they fly
drones from an ipad yeah they would be
better at that i was picturing like kids
third third graders getting gun safety
lessons in government school if it's
going to be in the united states
government schools that like if a
shooter comes in and kills the teacher
and there's 12 kids in the class ducking
for their desks and one of the kids sees
the teachers you know sidearm that the
teacher was killed before it could use
the kid what do you just want him to
huddle there until he gets shot
no i want the kid to pick up the gun and
end the shooter like i don't care if
they're 9 or 15 or 21 if they can do it
do it well let's let's let's phrase this
in a legal manner
children should be capable of defending
their lives or the lives of others yes
just like anyone else yep i mean
when it comes to your life yes they
should
well they want more autonomy for kids
when it comes to you know all the stuff
that they shouldn't have autonomy in but
when it comes to like actually teaching
kids to use guns like they used to in
schools like there are pictures from the
sick i would say the 50s and 60s where
middle schoolers are learning to shoot
like they're learning marksmanship they
were competing with each other i think
that's such a great idea and i wish that
we hadn't gotten rid of that yeah uh
welding as well yeah same idea carpentry
swords
sword fighting yeah we did that 101 with
professor poole yeah correct yes well no
james lindsay oh yeah yeah yeah i'm like
way more you know he's like trained with
gian yeah i'm way more bullish on gun
rights for kids because after this texas
thing man the cops stopped them from
going in and stopping it like you left
these kids to their own devices in a
classroom as they were getting mowed
down i am not comfortable with that yo
something weird is going on there
because like the left is entertaining
conspiracy theories about what happened
yeah tell me well
the cops aren't cooperating anymore with
the investigation the police stopped the
intervention and so the left is like
what is going on well it serves their
narrative because they hate cops right
so when you have a story about the cops
barring parents from saving their kids
and not going in themselves they're like
hmm what's this all about
then you've got the uh one of the guys
involved one of the cops i guess got a
seat on the city council or something so
the left has been pushing these these
conspiracy theories well also i mean
what happened there is the perfect
example of what gun control does the
police stop law-abiding citizens from
protecting from protecting themselves
and people they care about while the
maniac who kills people still doesn't
gets away with it
and that is the function that those
police officers served in that instance
yeah
i'm like obviously it'd be ridiculous to
give a third grader the right to carry
open carry a handgun but in the presence
of a supervised adult that is licensed
right maybe that you could legalize
their ability to handle one for training
purposes and then if it hits the fan you
know and it's wartime in the classroom
like it was in texas last week
these these young soldiers can defend
themselves
young soldiers they have no other choice
at that point my god a girl smeared
blood on her face and laid down so that
she looked dead so that she didn't get
killed i would have rather that she dove
for a handgun and ended the guy
no one else is going to do it and i have
to say that i think that the only way
out of this is to teach everyone
responsibility and i do mean everyone
the only way to stop active shooters
like this is to make them understand
that if they walk into a shop or store
that they hope to rob or a bank they
will be met with lethal force there is
no other way out i'm sorry to say it
that is the way of the world we've been
very protected we've lived in like this
marshmallow utopia for a really long
time we have a hard time seeing hard
truths it is interesting to see like my
friends who are all posting stuff about
like uh acab in like 2020 now saying
like well no you don't need a gun
the cops are gonna show up and they're
gonna save you and then the cops in an
instance where the cops didn't show up
and save them i was like it's a horrible
example this is like the out it's like
if this if this was like a police if
this was a movie about the police this
would be like the opposite of a movie
it's like they're the actually the worst
people on earth you got to speak their
language here's what i say to them do
you think that police are racist
well of course yes they say okay do you
think that white supremacists will give
up their guns if the guns are made
illegal no of course they won't okay do
you think racist cops will enforce the
law against white supremacists who
refuse to give their guns and they say
yeah of course they won't do you think
that police will use the justification
of gun checks to uh raid and violate the
the fourth amendment rights of black
people well yeah so you're saying you
want to pass a law that you think they
won't that racists won't enforce against
other racists but will be weaponized
against black and brown people yeah
sounds good
i mean that's that's the entirety of
their narrative cops are racist cops
don't cops protect other racists cops
arbitrarily enforce against black people
so they want laws and i said you know
what's going to happen i was like so
what a racist cop can go to any black
person's home and just say gun check
because you passed the red flag laws we
but i don't have any guns well we got a
wreck we got to search their house too
bad i'm like is that what you're
advocating for i mean
all gun control is racist well left-wing
positions don't involve that much for
thought here's what's required you say i
have good intentions pass my law okay
well what is your law going to result in
i have good intentions right okay what
what is the law going to do how do you
enforce it all of the concerns you
mentioned are those but i want good
thing and then and then i have questions
about good things sheamus you want bad
thing yeah you want bad things you want
bad thing you ask questions
that is literally the entire strategy
why do you want bad thing tim pulls on
the cover of the newspaper the next day
man want bad thing
it's totally insane and
basically the whole idea is let's look
at uh policy based on the intentions and
not the results or the incentives that
said policy creates
culturally can can this be a
multi-faceted approach like i i'm all
you know all with you on the gun side
too but npr
two three years ago did a mass shootings
can be contagious research shows which
is
extremely difficult the way the media
covers it too like can we all get on the
same page of how we're covering this
sort of stuff like you have to talk
about
there there are people in media who want
to shock to make money
so they're not going to tell you the
truth
they're then going to accuse us of
trying to shock to make money but the
fact that they will show the face and
the name of these murderers when what
they want is attention and they'll say
here's his manifesto read it
everything that he wanted here you go
well worse still is what happens is when
the manifesto comes out and clearly the
person's insane the media will latch
onto anything that smears the right yeah
so like here's a guy in uh was it
buffalo i think yeah who said he was a
he was a communist
he outright said he's like i'm
authoritarian left and they're like he's
right-wing
like well he was racist interesting but
you know he's crazy the adl says racism
is right-wing
i'm not even kidding if a racist attacks
someone it's listed as a right-wing
attack
so it's funny like the adl says right
wing is anti-government right-wing is
like uh bad they want bad thing right
but it's like racism bad therefore
racism right way but here's the if a
black nationalist who commits a racist
murder is left-wing and the left was
like what what like how was that left
wing
they asked the adl it's like black and
white are left and right i guess that's
that's that's how they can show up if an
asian commits a hate crime against the
hispanic is that right winger left-wing
that would probably
not be listed on the adl's website yeah
north yeah no i don't know
north yeah
they just put a question mark on the map
yeah they're like we don't know what
that means and we're not gonna engage
with it
but we had we had we've had black
nationalist killings we had one in
brooklyn and they say it's left wing
it's like but those guys have the same
ideology as hitler
well you know he was black though it's
like okay
but the white dude who who hates the
government like leftists take the
anti-far anarchists no i i shouldn't say
that many left-wing anarchists hate the
government and they're left like they're
they're you know anarcho-communists or
whatever
but if the person doesn't explicitly
explain that they're socialists it's
right-wing yep okay dude i feel like uh
a hurric as a tornado of identity
politics rip my brain out of my body in
the last like 37 minutes did you guys
feel like that that was a great phrase
it's it's just the the identity politics
are thick in this one yeah i don't know
how to respond to it because i can't i
feel like no no it's one of those things
where like acknowledging it causes it i
don't think that's it i think we do have
to acknowledge the division
but
i don't know it's i don't know is it
well is it identity politics to
acknowledge that specific political
groups are trying to do things that
they've outwardly stated they're trying
to do
if you just assume everyone in the group
is like adheres to the group authority
it is so if 10 people walk into a bank
and they're all wearing the same outfits
and they all came in the same truck and
then nine of them committed a bank robby
bank robbery and the last guy's like you
go get him guys and then you're like
you're all bank robbers he goes i didn't
do anything or would they get arrested
as charges accomplished he was the yeah
if he was the driver no no just someone
who was hanging out how bad he was just
standing there outside a group of ten
people walking into a bank all wearing
the same clothes nine of them commit the
robbery and the tenth one just stands
there watching and cheers them on you
thought it was a flash mob maybe yeah
how bad would your luck be if you just
happen to be wearing the same clothing
as bank robbers that day and you walk in
and they start robbing you like wait a
minute you ever seen thomas
no when like the guy steals the painting
and everyone's dressed in the same
clothes and so they're all moving around
like everyone's like where'd he go it's
him no he's there he's there like
there's just like some random guys
wearing the same clothes and he's like
oh crap
it's tough
when i get it's tough when we talk about
the democrats or like the left because i
know there's people that are
democrat that aren't crazy and then same
with the right right but that's why we
say they're they're npcs
because if at this point you're like
yeah jimmy dore had a segment the young
turks was ragging on him because he was
like if you're anti-war you vote for
trump and i'm like that is objectively
true correct trump didn't start any new
wars and he was pulling our trips out of
the middle east joe biden started a new
war oh well i should i shouldn't blame
him for something you know i say he he
put his he put our troops back into
these existing wars like syria
and now we have ukraine and they're
sending money and funds so it's like oh
more new war is happening i can't blame
him that's that's that's on russia
but if you voted for trump you have
abraham accords what is it uh was it
israel in the uae with a piece with a
free trade agreement i think yeah that's
crazy
that was uh almost none of my friends
had heard anything about that when we
talked about that when we talked about
this and they're like why would you
first of all i didn't tell them who i
voted for they just kind of assumed
whoever i might have voted for because i
i didn't uh post biden memes and talk
about that stuff and i just asked myself
do you have any idea about either the
abraham accords or the the pros the
progress we've made in the middle east
or north korea and they're just like
he's racist and i'm like oh
i can't even oh wow he is what did he
say it i tried to explain it in the
exams like the thing like you mentioned
with brandon strock about uh with uh
what was that with the
insulting the yeah for me it was the
ms-13 gang members and how they framed
how he said it as all
uh members you know all people from
mexico and it was like when i saw the
clip it was so egregious i'm like
you have to be at least somewhat aware
but most people aren't going to take the
time to actually look into it so i just
you know i always i always just you know
socratic method or
people say like yeah well trump's a
racist they'll go oh really oh yeah what
did he do
and then they're just like i don't know
that's crazy
yeah so you don't know that he did
anything racist here's another good art
school story i was having a conversation
with somebody and they mentioned that uh
they thought trump was racist against
immigrants and i pointed out that
immigrant was not a race and
they said that we should stop talking
politics
[Laughter]
usually what usually happens is um i'll
say like what what do you mean they'll
if they'll say something like trump is
racist against you know muslims yeah
they'll mention the muslim ban i'll be
like muslims not a race like do you mean
religious and they'll be like oh yeah
he's like bigot against religions and
i'm like oh like you like but the
countries that he ban is like venezuela
was included on that list and they'll be
like well that was a red herring i'll be
like oh you think that he was just like
it was a conspiracy
like he was pretending to ban venezuela
so that he could secretly ban muslims
and that was like a plot
and they'll be like well i'll be like i
don't know is that what you think like
the government was secretly plotting to
ban muslims so they pretended to ban
people from venezuela is that what
happened
i just don't i think i think it's just a
simple answer it's like trump banned a
bunch of countries because the obama
administration's doj or state department
said there was risks there
but you know whatever man trump did say
you know that he wanted to put a
moratorium or whatever on muslims
entering the country or whatever
also it's funny to point out to them
that obama was called deporter-in-chief
that blows their minds and they find out
how much uh how much he uh like how many
people he deported but also about most
of them don't know anything about the
drone strikes or anything that went on
before that because they weren't
politically initiated before the trump
presidency i think we should i should
hire canvassers the people who like
stand in the street and like wave to
people and just be like hey do you have
a minute to talk about the greatest
president never barack obama just five
seconds a little bit yeah sure what's up
like we are trying to get petitions
to
provide legal immunity for barack obama
because he killed an american child
without charge or trial we think that it
was an accident and he should not be
held accountable nor should he give up
his peace prize and we're looking for
signatures and they'll be like what
[Laughter]
it's like what and if they say no and be
like come on we don't want obama to get
in trouble over this yeah
he needed to kill that kid that's right
we want to talk about the disposition
matrix what's that like oh well it's
it's it's how he uh yeah so i figured
out
the disposition matrix
do you think people ever catch up to the
that sort of stuff like do you think
it ever will be
widespread enough that people understand
what's happening like for example like
uh
inflation numbers right inflation
numbers
didn't tick down which is what a lot of
people that i talk to think like oh yeah
inflation numbers went down because the
white house said it went down like no it
just didn't go up as much right do you
think anybody gets hip to that at any
point
yes that sort of will do i think a lot
of like i said it's npcs versus playing
characters yeah only the ones who are
already politically initiated and care
enough to look into it it would actually
wow enough to look farther at this point
the politically initiated people are
like i don't believe you anymore so now
no matter what they say it's like i'm
going to assume the opposite yeah
like media has become george castanza
where they just do everything opposite
it's a sacrifice to become you know a
critical thinker it requires a lot of
energy and it does it's are people
willing to make that sacrifice i don't
know
why do you have a reason to live if you
do then you'll probably make the
sacrifice
let's go to super chats if you have not
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and become a
member at timcast.com we're gonna have a
members only show coming up for you at
11 pm
and uh
we will uh we'll have a good show but
let's talk about these super chats
nomas says tim laugh and have fun with
joe bob as a guest
well okay i think we're getting done
yeah
matthew reckham says in regards to aldi
obviously it's wrong to shoot to shoot
cops but at what point do they stop
being cops to start being accomplices
that's the crazy thing they were
stopping the parents and not stopping
the shooter they were assisting the
shooter
that's crazy and it wasn't even them who
stopped him it was the border patrol did
it were they helping this kid well i'll
say this they helped him whether it was
on purpose or not you sure did that's
crazy man it is crazy
grofty says buck buck bach buck
indeed yes
words
insightful honestly it is it's a good
point he got he has the receipts adam
drop says hang on tim who among us
hasn't sent their father a porn link or
is it just hunter and i
yeah i think it's just hunter and you
man sorry
adrian contreras says tim said he
clicked on the hunter link for research
is that what they're calling it nowadays
tim
i was basically saying like
uh you know i'm not going to rag on
somebody for having you know weirdo
search history like you can rag on
hunter binding call them a degenerate or
whatever the bigger issue is the
political implications of sharing phone
numbers but i was like look i typed in
hunter biden you know
milf porn or whatever not to actually
watch it because i'm researching the
news and if someone saw that in my
browser history what would tim what are
you doing like no no you understand it's
a news thing and they're gonna be like
sure it was
sure
all right clear tim's browser history if
he dies
dagger says ian look up edward bernays
his uncle and his nephew mind-blowing
psychological propaganda he's the father
of modern propaganda i believe
uh american theorist considered as a
pioneer in the field of public relations
and propaganda didn't he like make bacon
a thing i don't know like breakfast i
think me and andy talked about that i
think yeah
i do enjoy bacon but like sauce oh maybe
something else i don't know about that i
looked into that but uh orange juice i
think he did
like orange juice is horrible for you
it's like really really bad sugar yeah
yeah and the idea was
there was an orange surplus which meant
the price was going to drop and the
farmers were like what can we do to make
sure we sell all these oranges and he
said make a new product they came up
with orange juice and said if an orange
is healthy
a glass of orange juice is even more
healthy it's like hot wings so same
thing with chickens like they they
couldn't figure out what to do with the
wings and so now you have hot wings for
you really i think chicken wings yeah no
i know but i'm pretty sure i'm pretty
sure people generally ate the breast of
the thigh shut up yeah i'm pretty sure
that's where the pork rib comes from
they have a surplus in a certain month
of the year and that's what they put it
into edward vernes his family was not
involved with the bernays so spelled
differently
thomas sidebottom says sheamus i watched
the oldest video on the freedom tunes
channel the other day you've grown so
much and come so far i love seeing that
keep it up thank you so much yeah that
would be how government works and that's
uh you know this fall it will have been
eight years oh that was funny the guy's
like i'm gonna buy a thousand a lot more
yes yeah yeah you guys gotta check it
out it's like what does he say so the
whole idea is should i spoil it or
should they go see it it just gives the
gist so the whole gist is like a guy
comes through his house and he's like
i'm the social contractor and he's like
what's your superpower he's like i build
and buy things without your consent
regardless of whether you want them and
then expect you to pay for it when i'm
done that's right it's like that's a
terrible superpower
but but then he has like something and
then he's like i noticed your car was
broken so i hired a repairman and the
car gets fixed and your roof was leaking
so i hired a roofer oh this is actually
pretty pretty nice and i noticed you
didn't have a cat so i ordered you 6 000
tons of cat food why would you do this
well my friend does own the cat food
factory
but go check it out if you really want
to see how far we've come
freedomtunes.com become a member five
bucks a month get an extra cartoon every
week and see a bunch of cartoons that we
have up there now you guys are gonna
love them neil sawyer says hey shimsham
i tried to use potatoes to pay for my
membership to freedom tunes but for some
reason it only let me use this garbage
currency called usd yeah so i've been
seriously the best 10 bucks i've ever
spent thank you thank you so much
that's more and that is very generous
because that is more than we ask
anything above five bucks is completely
voluntary so thank you so much for
giving that and yeah i have been talking
to the web developers about
the uh the uh potato payment processing
possibilities they just send those to
you directly yeah yeah so you're we're
gonna have to get a po box set up just
because paypal will shave off like 10
percent of the potato oh yeah and i
don't know i'm not letting someone else
have 10 of my potatoes what about nft
potatoes so i've thought about it um
my the part of the part of why i want
potatoes as payment is it's an infl it's
a hedge against inflation
um but i don't know about nfts i don't
think they're going to perform well in
the the long term
they kind of but they sting you know
when you eat them raw yeah yeah exactly
i mean did they they're even better
rotten no i'm trying to tell people
because i have a punch that's accurate
kentaro bella says they just killed the
daily wire live stream
i don't know if that's true i don't know
did they interesting
some people are pointing out that when
we brought up world trade center seven
the stream cut out and then skipped and
like
people it always happens at
you know these these particular moments
in the show
uh i
my show is never skipped except for when
i talk about hillary clinton
and i'm not i don't actually think
that's like legit it's just really weird
that it i i
have been to these live streaming
headquarters for a bunch of different
companies they have people
who have big monitors and they can see
like a hundred live streams all at once
and then they're watching each going and
when they see someone start to do
something
they drag it and drop it into a
watchlist
yeah
so literal typically what they're what
they're doing is looking for cam girls
and so as soon as they see someone start
to do something they put them on a watch
list pay more attention to it and then
as soon as they see it close they nuke
it
i don't know if they can do that for a
lot of youtube stuff
i do believe they probably have someone
watching this show every night
like this show probably watching crowd
lucky
yeah
leave a comment if you're watching hey
if you work at youtube if you if you
work youtube when you're watching this
go to freedomtunes.com
become a member i know you're making
enough money to subscribe at the highest
level please do so
all right oh hell no says depp
originally lost seven million dollars
and now he wins 15 but only gets 10.35
but she wins 2 million in her suit so in
the end depp only came out 1.3 1.35
million on top but still has all his
lawyer fees all right to be fair he got
out of doing the harry potter movie too
that's fair and so the judge actually
ordered him to pay amber hurd over that
he's like to be fair you were your
career was saved actually that was
actually they said i said they should
have just had her pay the seven million
he paid in uh his divorce settlement
backed him if they wanted to be poetic
i'm not seeing anything about the daily
wire streaming pulled down it's up now
they finished it uh it was an hour and a
half long although it did end about an
hour in then they go to some pre-record
all right sevy rose says why would you
share a pornhub premium link unless you
knew the recipient also did yeah they'd
both have to have premium imagine
hunter's like he's like hey dad uh
what's going on son you got to see this
porn man i'm sending it to you i was
like great thanks
even they don't want to pay for ads
that's great
all right
darren darien says this behavior is
endemic of every facet of power the
bidens are nothing new they're simply an
example that we need uh new blood in
congress anyone can throw their hat in
let me be an example of that wish us
luck here in california well good luck
good sir
chance bell says do you guys think it'd
be possible to get maxim bernier on the
show maxim bernie bermi uh bernier he's
the leader of the ppc up in canada our
growing populist party he deserves more
exposure if we're going to survive the
socialist hellhole love you ian i love
you too yeah i'm i'm down i don't know
did you have a bunch of stuff happen
during the freedom convoy uh am i
misremembering that i don't know he got
like uh jailed or got in trouble or
something during the i think i remember
chaos with him he does have a standing
invite from us when i hit him up he was
so busy there was no way he was gonna be
able to make it but that race is over so
maybe yeah hopefully raymond g stanley
jr says step on snaka and find out i
love him we made step on snack and find
out skateboards and we have a whole
bunch of them and i don't even know what
we're doing with them we just have them
we should uh do a raffle or something
yeah okay yeah we should do that yeah
all right
hippie kitty says did hunter send his
dad the videos that he uploaded to
pornhub of himself oh man that's what i
was afraid of dad look what i did oh my
gosh hey hey dad be proud of me look
what i did that's mighty good son oh no
that's crazy
joel
xlin says watch the video of jeff
sessions slapping biden's hand away when
he reached for jeff's granddaughter i
can't believe no one mentions that one
jeff obviously knows what a creepy is
incredible yeah i think i remember that
did you remember that creepy stuff
though adrian contreras has the clintons
house lannister rich but everyone hates
them the bidens house baratheon
incompetent but can still stir things
but can start things up the bushes house
targaryen going extinct trump house
stark fan favorite
but nobody likes that show anymore so i
don't know
sir lemongrab says with the cult with
the culture divide
it's like we are watching the left and
liberals fighting over hand grenade and
we are trying to stop them from pulling
the pin
i know that's why i'm like dude just you
know go about your business
make money
speak up
build culture focus on you do your thing
you know
mike ross says
the hoops you have to jump through to
share a cell phone number is a bit wild
i manage a 1.6 i manage a 1.6 billion
dollar company's network and phone plan
is not normal
wow
i can't think of a sink simply like a
single example in history of like
somebody like having the same phone
number as somebody else like on purpose
any reason why you would either right
doesn't make any sense yeah i think tim
is right i think that's totally cover
for joe working as hunter really
interesting yep
it's a text from it's hunter's phone but
joe's the one sending the messages yeah
all right
ann phillips says new commercial kid
dreams about high gas prices immigrants
taking jobs then wakes up wakes up
asking if joe biden is still president
no no no no here's the new commercial
it's the exact same commercial but that
guy's truck immediately breaks down
because he's out of gas
biden a better america that's right yes
again the children wake up thank
goodness the kids are running the car
breaks down and the kids stop running
and they're like we're safe and then joe
walks up and he's like thank me kids i'm
the one who made it and the guy gets out
of the truck and he goes curse you joe
you don't think it would be a hilarious
political ad if we have time for it or
just right now is a
exact same ad of some congressman a is a
lifelong nra supporter he's endorsed by
donald trump and supported all of donald
trump's policy he wants to build a wall
in our southern border and supports the
overturning of roe vs wade have that be
an actual commercial then do the same
exact copy with a minor tone key in it
congressman
is a donald trump supporter he wants to
build a wall on our southern border and
end roe versus wade that is hilarious
you know i a while ago
i can't remember if it was vice or vox
but there was a mini documentary on this
fellow who was 3d printing firearms
and all they did is they took footage of
him uh in an interview where he was
speaking to them
and he was just speaking reasonably
about
the fact that because of 3d printing
technology it's going to be difficult to
regulate guns and americans have a right
to keep them bearing arm but keep and
their arms but they played scary
sounding
underneath it so i was like oh he's back
yeah yeah that's my favorite and the
minor key they turn up the shadows and
make your inside your face look darker
well here's an idea like why don't you
take a joe biden ad or a democrat ad and
then just redub it in a minor key with a
low voice that'd be fun so you know it's
a guy's like i want to
you know forgive student loan you know
yeah john smith wants to forgive student
loan debt and help americans find a you
know help immigrants find a better path
john smith wants to pay off
college debt
joe biden protects children by trying to
detect if there are harmful chemicals in
their hair that's right
he's checking for breasts that's a good
one you should make a compilation of all
the
sniffing oh my goodness oh you know what
no no actually actually here's here's a
good bit it's um biden gets word
that uh you know china or russia
russia's better better country has uh
tainted shampoo
and they're like mr president
russia has sent tainted shampoo to this
country children's shampoo
how are we going to be able to find out
which kids were affected by it's like
i'll do it i have to for the children in
this country most of all of them man
or actually it might be funnier if joe
biden claims that
he's like i got a report uh you know
russia's
uh tainted children's shampoo so i'm
gonna have to sniff these kids just to
make sure you know the only way to make
sure man i don't know if that's true mr
president don't you doubt me
mr biden we can hire people for that
he's like do it myself i'm gonna do it
myself
is awfully uh well-equipped cognitively
yeah
proto says in ancient sparta public
officials held their posts for one year
at the end of which they were
immediately put on trial let's try that
that's a great idea
what did you do because they knew
they're like look there's no way you can
be a politician for a year and not
commit a crime that's right look at
illinois governors yep andrew biko says
what are your thoughts on an american
citizen's right to an offense uh to an
offensive attorney would this provide
the middle class with the ability to
level the playing field however new
issues may arise from it i don't know
how we do that that's tough like public
defenders are bad enough like public
defenders are usually like they walk in
they're like plead guilty and you're
like but i didn't do it and plead guilty
you're like they have no evidence i did
anything
do you draw the line
like can can you just sue anybody for
anything as long as the taxpayer is
paying for it you can't yeah right by
offensive lawyer i mean like a lawyer is
not going to use your pronouns
ashley hay says taking tim's perspective
yesterday we need stickers praising joe
biden for defeating climate change any
ideas on something catchy
um defeat you know
i don't know like how about big stickers
with really verbose memes that are just
impossible to read explaining
yeah like the elections like you need to
understand that the goal here with the
with the restrictions on on gas prices
was to make sure that carbon emissions
would be reduced
and then people are going to be like wow
yeah that's leftist mean
ratsu says my daughter was just born 5
25 today what did i miss happy birthday
my love
nyasa west congratulations
congratulations it's exciting
aina is jesus here's an idea keep the
two four-year terms but they can't be
back-to-back and no running for
re-election while president that's a
good one interesting why is that better
than one six years because they can't
campaign while they're in office yeah
they have to be out of office yeah
so they're not going to run for
reelection so they'll campaign in the
middle of the next person's election
you're going to have you're going gonna
have ex-presidents sucking up a lot of
attention i like the success that's
doing now yeah like obama's better or
jimmy carter i mean like some of these
guys don't i mean historically it's been
kind of the uh the norm that the
ex-president doesn't talk about the
current president but that has been
shattered yeah
i feel like that would be the issue
rebecca crane says got in late but salsa
had an active shooter at a hospital
democrats are going to go after guns
even harder now yeah it's really funny
that the media is highlighting all of
these stories now isn't it right before
an election isn't that interesting some
of them are obvious like when the kids
you know are getting shot at i get it
but chicago has this stuff happening all
the time and ain't nobody talking about
it
prince swagetta
swagetta to me ubi means the government
takes their grubby hands out of my
pocket i would never have financial
problems again
there you go
people are mentioning tulsa man it's
crazy
uncle sam says fact check your lachenko
leaks war plans video is false look at
map
first cav emblem top right u.s army unit
the map is from 2014 he applied to be a
fact checker for you i was in that unit
uh
oh that's a video from several months
ago i don't know
well i'll take a look at it i suppose
leaks war plan video what they were
saying was that this dude had a map of
ukraine showing movements and they
believed that it showed movements that
had not yet happened yet
i suppose he's saying this was from
2014.
all right let's see
nsx says i'm about 50 minutes behind but
sounds like you guys are getting a few
facts wrong however you'll find out in
coming days i'm sure and yes this was an
awesome win clearly a hoax if you watch
the trial interesting
all right lurch says i'll never
understand why people who lisp host
podcast it's so annoying
who lisps i don't know
me me ian i don't know
they said this they're trying to like
gaslight us
he's got a stutter yeah that's right
ethan klein a stutter that makes him a
stutter that makes him say being a uh
poor kid precludes you from being a
white kid that's right it's like you
know one of those solids rook ave says i
agree with generic luke who's that
generic luke is this sheamus
i think luke will be back next week
he'll be here next week i think so and
i'm really excited for when we show him
little luke the rooster the cockroach
yeah so we got a polish chicken he's a
cockroach so it's gonna be a rooster and
he's got big bushy blonde hair because
the polish ones have like big hair and
he's got a big nose and he's blonde and
he's polish so we were like well he's a
little luke
and then you know luke's the one who
said he's got my nose that's right so
we're like he does we just called him
luke because he was blonde and polish
and he had like a little haircut kind of
like he looked angry because they sound
kind of similar yeah they don't yeah
that's true
[Laughter]
9 11.
we're going to say and believed
[Laughter]
yeah that's a good one
wolf rick of wessex says the democrats
are going to try and push gavin newsom
as the front runner maybe not this cycle
but certainly by 2028
man there is no person in this country
that wanted donald trump to win more
than gavin newsom interesting thing in
2020
i can go into that if you want but
that's that's that's my theory
interesting
well because gavin wants to run for
president oh yeah
that was his best option trump were to
win he would run in 2024 as a sitting
governor now
he's like as plastic as plastic i'm not
saying he's going to be good at it i'm
just saying he wants to do that
and i'm sorry he's he's beats here yeah
he comes off like a generic politician
yeah
again i'm not saying he's good at that's
just him that his trajectory had donald
trump winning and it got screwed up he's
one of those guys that does this when he
talks
i think him and mitt romney were
actually made at the same factory yeah
yeah trudeau's factory for sure
mark h says recently a man opened fire
on a graduation party in charleston west
virginia with an ar-15 that's correct
woman with a carry permit took her
handgun out and killed the suspect
but you don't need a carry permit in
west virginia so i'm not sure she
actually had one but maybe she did but
you don't need one anyway it's a
constitutional carry state well it's
true they said charleston that might
they may be talking about south south
carolina no this is no it's not genuine
okay
well we know the story we talked about
oh okay um i just want to say that the
supreme court is currently going over a
court case related to guns and i'm just
crossing my fingers for a broad ruling
that basically says constitutional
nation would
maybe yeah
the the thing is in new york they're
trying to ban body armor and long guns
it's like basically ban everything
and um i don't know where they're at
with that right now but there's a
there's a lawsuit because
in new york you're you can't get a gun
you can file for one and they like tell
us why you need it and you're like it's
my right too bad and they throw it in
the garbage you don't get it so they
sued the supreme court's reviewing this
it's possible to do a broad ruling and
say states cannot require a permit for
owning a gun what do you think the
carrying one
i don't know i don't know about that one
i think at low probably
because even even scalia said second
amendment is not absolute
which is just ridiculous
like
we know exactly what kind of weapons
they had back then they we knew about
the advancements in weaponry they the
founding fathers knew it if you want to
amend the second amendment because of
the advancement of weaponry by all means
let's have that conversation but just to
come out and be like we've decided that
weapons are too powerful so your rights
are gone i'm like no it doesn't sound
right yeah that's what i'm saying well
the founders didn't know about the
internet the internet's changed
everything don't care you've got to
change the constitution and adapt to
these things you can't just ignore it
that's where we're at though
darth professor says great conversation
everyone my concern about the upcoming
election is the dems will do the same
thing as they did in 2020 dams have
tripled down on their agenda bill
clinton changed course even obama to
keep people on the dem side of
popularity
we'll see i suppose
i think so
let's see are
arthur messiah
i covered the tulsa shooting at saint
francis i was the first to break the
news my wife is a nurse there and was in
lockdown my kids were at the daycare
there i got to them i got them 10
minutes before it started wow my gosh
crazy scary
man
iron lord oni
the young girl shooting the two guns
have a youtube channel called autumn's
armory she's awesome check her out well
there you go
crandall logan you can only have an
opinion and make laws on certain guns if
you currently own and practice with that
type of gun and you can only have an
opinion make laws on background checks
if you have passed a knicks background
check i love when beta was like you know
people shouldn't be allowed to have air
15s or an ak47s i was watching i wish i
was there to be like um mr o'rourke what
about
this
scar 20s well that too mr what about an
m1a no well that's it what about uh
literally any other rifle
all of them
robert
yeah we're gonna ban this one gun
francis
robert
that's not even your real name that's
right bato
dragon stallion or stalin oh oh dragon's
talon there we go lydia fifth graders
learn to shoot guns by using school gym
as target range wyoming idaho statement
paper yeah but that was airsoft
i don't know i was shocked and offended
i said those kids should not be using
those websites right yeah they should be
outside with ruger 10 22's of course
yeah
airsoft
no i mean to be honest like airsoft for
kids to start training is probably a
good way to start yeah i learned i
started learning to shoot i think when i
was about seven with bb guns then we
gradually went up from there and it just
worked great a little safer
clint torres says brett hey bro sorry
couldn't make your last episode but good
thing i never missed him well there you
go thank you yes we are doing the show
live now every day 3 p.m monday through
friday monday through friday 3pm
youtube.com pop culture crisis indeed
yeah we've got big plans for big
marketing push
making that show big
subscribe
oscary says tim check out brandon
tatum's take with uvaldi shooting he had
the inside scoop from the officers on
site interesting
rage 8 says what did michael males say
about cops killing kids arm our teachers
bring back marksmanship in schools and
issue every citizen a free firearm i'm
not sure i want to give groomers guns
i don't know about that one no not all
teachers should have maybe age 25 people
could apply to a rifle or something like
that well what do you mean
government-issued rifle uh 16.
that's so young well we drive cars 16.
that's also young very dangerous so if
you pass firearm ed you get your you get
your license you go to school they have
elective you can you or you don't i
didn't do diver's ed i just turned 18
and when got my license to me like an
hour so then if you don't do that when
you're 18 you can go in and fill out a
general knowledge question you know like
you got you got to know how to load it
you got to know where the safety is you
got to know how to point they'll ask you
basic questions like what are the four
basic rules and then you get your
government issued you know air the best
argument against this i'm somewhat
kidding by the way but they were like
government subsidizing weapons will
drive the price up to ridiculous numbers
and make it hard for people to buy yeah
there will be like yeah no if the
government promises everyone a free gun
there will be a gun shortage in like two
weeks
please
there you go
spiro fluoropolis says according to
sources say dot online ian has created a
lover from graphene lol
so i recently got this um i got an ad on
facebook for an ai
text generator
and it's marketed as a tool for helping
you write whether it's news product
marketing or blog posts
and so it's actually so much fun i have
an idea i think we should do
we're going to do like a chicken city
cartoon
i wrote uh i put the inputs in it was
like ian witch
cat
graphene federal reserve and it wrote
two paragraphs about ian being a
scientist who was trying to formulate
graphene but a witch came and like stole
stole his banana something
it was awesome and i'm like we should
totally just you know do aiai bits
what's this website called
i think it's called jasper
something like that
i don't know google ai the text
generator yeah yeah and so you could
write news stories so the crazy thing is
it actually knows the news and so i
tested this out and is that what it was
called jasper.ai is that yeah i typed in
um joe biden
gas prices
uh record levels and then it wrote two
paragraphs of new story and it was like
gas prices have reached a new record
level under the presidency of joe biden
blah blah blah i was like whoa yeah at
the very least this is the narration
that would play over like a funny thing
you know funny skit
sometimes cheap [ __ ] you can't really
use it i mean it's it's funny it's a gag
but i'm surprised that
anyone would actually use it as a
product right it's good um like
inspiration if you want to write
something about these topics this could
give you like a oh okay right exactly
it'll it'll it'll that's the only thing
it really is like a muse because you can
do creative story and that's what i did
for the ian graphene thing
but like you can't continue the story so
it'll write you a paragraph or two
paragraphs and then you can't continue
the story because if you put in new
inputs based on the old paragraph it
creates a different story
i mean it's interesting yeah well joe
biden's using it to write his speeches
yeah kamala harris is
and it's an auto ai generator and she's
just like the dog went to the store and
ukraine's small and i'm the president
and they're like what is she saying then
it gets confused and she laughs yeah
[Laughter]
let's grab some more super chats
duder says hunter and joe shared bank
accounts so why would they need 10 for
the big guy because the big guy is obama
whoa
[Music]
everybody at
blew our minds with that one the big guy
is obama well it it definitely blew my
mind that listen you're joking
you're gonna cut me in on this deal or
i'm gonna
beat you mercilessly uh i will tell on
you i'll tell on you if you don't cut me
the deal these are both actually very
impressive
i will mercilessly beat you yeah joe i
will beat you with a 2x4 until you are
no longer able to form a coherent
sentence i mean and joe didn't pay him
and that's what happened
24.
come on all right
andrea
guerra samenco the dual wielding
seven-year-old has a youtube channel
called autumn's armory you guys check
her out
yes yes absolutely
all right we can grab a couple more here
reggae vibe says i'd like to tell biden
supporters don't you wish you voted for
vermin supreme you'd have got it
you'd have gotten no trump and you would
have taken our guns and given us better
ones yeah we all would have won free
pony yeah
yeah that was three points mandatory
toothbrushing yes yeah
k.a collins says tim and crew come out
and be treated vip at the original rock
and roll of hillbillies of chaos on june
4th at paradise city plaza appalachia va
love to see you oh we'll take a look at
that
oh that's saturday isn't it it sounds
like it oh it's coming saturday oh yeah
how far away is that where is it
paradise city plaza
va west virginia let's let's look that
up real quick i'm curious now
are you typing it in yeah paradise city
where is it far away no appalling i
can't go but you guys have fun
all right
amy nw says i texted my mom the moment
the suspect sussman verdict was
announced and her exact response after a
few profanities was so it's over civil
war or bust and it immediately made me
think of the show cheers to tim cass
from california hey
how far away is it oh geez six hours
seven hours oh too far ladies and
gentlemen if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com we're gonna have that
members only show coming up we've got um
we got some not so family-friendly and
offensive stuff to talk about so that's
always fun and you can follow the show
at tim cast irl follow us on instagram
because we post clips all day every day
you can follow me personally at tim cast
on instagram or twitter joe bob you want
to shout anything out yeah just uh
j-o-b-o-b type it pretty much anywhere
and if it's a brown guy with a hillbilly
name that's probably me
check out the daily caller live show
each and every morning on all the daily
caller platforms and watch out for the
star-spangled banter tour which i'm not
entirely sure what that is yet but right
on
uh guys you can follow me uh brett
dasvik on instagram and then follow pop
culture crisis on youtube we are now
live monday through friday 3 p.m that's
12 p.m pacific i always say if you're in
california eat a burrito at lunch come
watch us it's great we're also on amazon
music apple podcast pandora spotify you
can listen to us there it's a lot of fun
we'll see you there cool i'm sheamus
goggle and i have youtube channel called
freedom tunes we're going to be
releasing a new cartoon tomorrow i think
you guys are really going to enjoy it i
also have a website called
freedomtunes.com if you want to go there
check it out become a member five bucks
a month you'll get a bunch of extra
exclusive cartoons that i think you'll
enjoy uh i'm looking to find a couple of
ux artists that are interested in
working with uh the charity that i'm
setting up to build this uh open source
technology that we're working on we're
very very far along on the project but
we need some artists so if you're a ux
artist and you want to get involved uh
from the ground up hit me up on twitter
on mines and let me know and i'll get
you roped in also this is a book that i
wrote i talked about it last night it's
called writing in the dark it was like a
kind of a diary when i was co-founding
minds i'm just gonna leave it there but
with one more thing please um do your
best to
think outside the box
love you ma'am
solid advice from ian everybody is
talking something i just have sour patch
lid stop me you guys can find all my
socials over there we will see you all
over at timcast.com thanks for hanging
out
you